Not too long ago, Zoombinis enjoyed the good life.
Though they all looked slightly different, different eyes, noses, hair, teeth...
Such differences meant nothing to the Zoombinis.
And so they lived happily on Zoombini Isle, making small, useful products which were prized the world over.
The Zoombinis had a sense of fulfillment and inner peace, not to mention healthy bank accounts.
Then one day, who should show up but the Bloats.
The Bloats offered to help the Zoombinis grow their businesses, expand their trade routes, and improve their quality of life.
Nice!
Being trusting sorts, the Zoombinis agreed.
Oh wait, no, we do hate those guys!
They're bad guys!
But before long, the Bloats had taken over everything.
No!
Stealing profits.
Canceling holidays.
High holidays!
Piling on work.
Oh my god.
The Zoombinis were getting pretty stressed out.
Oh, they're stressed!
Well, you can push them only so far before they take matters into their own hands.
Viva la revolucion!
Zoombinis!
Oh my god.
And so they decided to escape.
Escape.
And build a new home in a distant land!
Oh my gosh, sorry.
Hello everybody!
Welcome back!
Master!
Lady!
Hello!
Hello hello hello!
Welcome!
Oh, I guess I could have gotten to this part and then clicked watch intro.
But I wasn't sure...
If it would be okay.
So...
Hello!
Hello hello!
Welcome to a Zoombi...
I love this game.
From my ghostly childhood.
When I was a wee wisp.
And I would play this game.
I would...
I can remember so many sound effects from this game.
I'm so sorry.
I'm gonna be so annoying.
But this one is like...
I guess...
The remake.
I guess technically it's a remake.
And it...
Has like...
New art.
And...
I don't...
I think...
That's it though.
Thank you!
Can you guys hear the...
Donuts?
I turned down the volume quite a bit.
Because the Zoombini game was so loud.
But I can hear them.
So I can see...
I can see...
Your stuff.
Cracks me up how much...
Of the story of Zoombinis went over my head as a kid.
Yeah.
I...
I'll be honest.
I remember them...
They having to...
Leave.
I remember them having to leave.
Thank you for the dough.
No.
Because...
Um...
Uh...
Because of something.
I couldn't remember why.
It's actually missing some sound effects I think.
Don't tell me that.
I might cry.
I might actually cry.
They did that to me in Spiral.
There was like...
It's the smallest thing in Spyro.
In Spyro 2.
Ripto's Rage.
When they remade it.
And the one world with the guys that...
That do the ice skating.
And there's the evil spirits that you have to exorcise.
They go...
Why I am...
They do that in the original.
But they changed it for some reason.
In the remake.
I don't know why.
It makes me so sad.
But...
You know.
It is what it is.
Here I think...
At least the voices are the same as you could hear from Crunchy Narrator-san.
He sounds so...
The Zoombinis.
That's what he talks like.
Let's enter my name.
We don't...
No.
I'm gonna have the smiley.
Alright.
So this is a game.
Where we're little Zoombinis.
And if you don't know what this game is.
Yeah.
We're little...
Well, we're not...
We are guiding the Zoombinis to salvation.
We are leading them from the terrors of the working world.
To...
To a new world where they will have holidays again.
Yeah!
And...
To a new world where
they can escape from the curse.
I remember.
I used to sit on the screen.
Because there would be a crab.
Boom.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Ronan.
Thank you so much for the Dono.
I don't know if you'll see this or not.
But I want to know that you inspired me to follow and support Vtubers who ran these And showed me the beautiful world of them.
I wouldn't be a Vtuber fan today if it weren't for you, my dear Kamioshi Mint Boss!
Sorry for taking time.
Not at all.
Thank you, Ronin.
You're... you know...
If you found where you belong, you're not a Ronin anymore.
Isn't that the case?
One of us.
Amy, thank you!
Tyranzor, thank you!
I love zumbinis.
Zumbinis also fart, so...
Or if you think you would start my new job tomorrow...
Congrats?
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Usually I will read the donos at the end of the stream, so...
Yes, thank you guys so much.
Thank you.
Okay!
Oh my gosh, we get to create our zumbinis!
Wait, what's the multiple dice versus the one dice?
Oh my god!
No!
No, no!
Go back into the hole!
Get back in your hole!
No!
Oh my gosh, no.
Who are these strangers?
No!
No, they don't stop!
Stop!
Stop it!
No!
Oh, they're talking over...
I don't know who you are!
Get in there!
Yeah, yeah, get in there!
I don't know who you are!
You are not welcome on my boat!
Get in there!
Sorry, this is an exclusive club, okay?
Yeah, this is...
This is...
You know...
Okay.
Thank you so much!
I have no idea what this game is about.
I look forward to find out why this holds a special place in your heart.
Already starting strong.
I think the puzzles in this are a lot of fun.
I would have to say my favorite one would maybe be...
There's a froggy one.
Where you release little froggies.
Um...
And they have to follow a certain path.
Wait!
I can't name it myself?
Oh no!
I wanted to name...
I wanted to name them after you.
Joan!
Have fun again today!
We love you our most!
Beloved ghost maid Joan!
Oh my god!
I hope you're good!
Oh my gosh!
Isashi booty Joan!
Are you still doing nursing?
You're still good?
We can change our names to them.
No!
Don't do that!
Okay.
Well maybe it would be easier to just...
No, no.
Okay.
Alright guys.
Oh my gosh!
She's so cute!
With the backwards hat and everything.
Arigato!
Thank you guys for the donuts!
Thank you!
Let's see.
Our first friend.
The cool glasses.
Green.
Like me.
Floating.
Oh!
Ah!
Okay.
Alright.
Jernuagi!
Release!
Yeah!
Kwaru is dead.
Oh sorry.
Also.
Cyclops!
Cyclops skater!
Katie!
Release!
Jernuagi goes hard.
Kwaru is dead!
No no he's not!
No he's not!
He's...
Deiso!
Uh oh.
Okay hold on.
I gotta not go so fast.
I might pass it.
These are some crazy...
I don't know how to pronounce any of these.
Frofa!
Release Frofa!
Um...
Seiso Deiso.
Yeah.
Frofa.
Cthulhu names.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Oh the beady eyes are so funny.
I like the springy ones too.
But they're a little slow.
Let's do...
Sigu!
Boing boing boing.
Boing boing.
Sounds like my name is Kwaru now.
No.
Um...
Crazy hairs.
Sneeflu.
Sneeflu!
Like I'm just walking.
Walk walk walk.
I'm gonna call her walk.
Who am I missing?
We got flying, we got skating.
Okay we need a lot of guys though.
I'm gonna get this one random.
Ladle!
Release Slato!
He went bald.
Red nose?
Oh we do need a red nose.
Oh yeah we need a lot of colors for the future.
For future things.
Oh we also don't have this hairstyle.
I think that...
Hype...
Emma.
It's EE!
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
EE!
It looks just like Emma.
So cranky.
Let's see what else do we need.
Rebrual!
What's wrong with EE?
Robracio!
I think they're siblings.
Denise!
You know what?
I am just gonna random...
random generate them now because...
Igagaga!
Muscus!
We need another Cyclops.
Cyclops!
Wait you have the same hair though.
Let's give you this hair.
Two!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
It's been forever!
Hello!
There's some beanies I was taking from the hole.
Either truly Wisp.
Or truly Fantomy.
Stop.
Let's see what... Oh!
Sorry.
Everyone's gotta be different.
Daffyro!
Um...
What other...
Oh!
Kaislu!
Wait, we have a lot of glasses.
Hold on.
What do we need more of?
We need more beady eyed people.
Fleece!
You're not Fleece!
Well, whatever you are.
Make me a pizza!
Um...
We have a couple sleepy eyes.
We need more beady eyes.
Come on.
Oh!
Emiliano!
How many more people can I have?
Thank you guys for all the donuts!
Thank you!
Oh, you don't even have a name.
Oh, this is it!
This is the crew everybody.
The journey begins here.
Zumbini Isle.
Select traits to create a crew of 16 Zumbinis.
But remember, each Zumbini in this crew must be unique.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, guys.
I think it's time.
Boom boom boom boom.
Why is the music so...
The day is tossed about by a stormy sea.
The Zumbinis reach the shore of the peculiar land.
That's a big crab.
Wait, that's a huge crab.
Okay, so our first puzzle is getting across the bridge.
Why was the crab so big?
Okay.
So this puzzle...
Each...
Each man...
This game is kind of creepy.
This game is a little scary.
So...
Why is there a face in that cliff?
That's what I'm about to tell you.
These cliffs are alive!
And they're also very picky.
So we have these bridges.
That...
The Zumbinis can cross either one or the other.
So some traits...
This guy likes.
But this guy doesn't like.
And we only have this number of tries.
To figure out where the Zumbinis go.
So he's gonna...
He's gonna sneeze.
Alright, Denise.
Let's check...
Let's try this way.
Okay.
That was fast.
Okay, so...
We'll put you over here.
But what trait did he not like?
They got a type.
Yeah, they do.
Sniffle.
So...
Let's try the hair.
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
A simp.
A soup.
Sigma cliffs.
Look at...
Even the rocks have faces.
Does that mean the ground is alive too?
Am I like stepping on...
Like this guy's got a face.
It's all faces.
Okay, uh...
So maybe it's glasses, no glasses?
So glasses here?
Oh!
You think?
Glasses?
Oh!
Y'all...
I think we're geniuses.
This children's game got nothing on us.
Hahaha!
Yahoo!
Oh!
Okay...
Our theory...
Has been debunked.
What?
Is it...
Two eyes, one eye?
So everyone's...
Going on this side.
What's wrong with cyclopses?
Two eyes...
That would make sense...
Because I put...
I mean, with glasses...
You're gonna have two eyes.
Yippee!
Oh my god, they're so loud.
I'm gonna be adjusting the volume like crazy in this game.
I'm so sorry.
Yes!
Me!
Oh wait, what is this?
Oh wait, oh no no.
Stay with him!
Stay with me!
Feeling stuck?
Don't worry brave explorer.
You have all the information you need to complete this challenge.
Get all your zumbinis through.
Take your time.
Look for patterns and don't be afraid to make mistakes.
Allergic cliffs.
Why are you allergic to my zumbinis?
If a few of our little blue friends are left behind...
They'll be waiting at zumbini aisle.
Oh no!
We could have lost them!
Okay.
First trial.
These stone guards have their rules.
So do proceed with skill.
Zumbinis one guard won't allow.
The other guard surely will.
Okay, so it's similar.
It's similar like before.
Hello mint, hello!
The floodgates are opened it seems.
They're blue!
Um...
Okay.
They're blue!
What about it?
Actually I'm green.
I'm mint.
A little bit of blue.
Okay, let's just...
Katie, you're up first baby.
No!
Why are you so rude?
Okay, so basically it's the same as before.
Just a little bit more.
And if they like...
If they ground pound enough...
The rocks will come flying down.
So...
Hmm.
This way.
Uh-uh.
Why do you say it like that?
To my girl Katie.
Okay.
Thank you grandma.
Oh, she didn't even say anything.
Okay.
So...
Alright.
Let's try the hair again.
Let's do hair again.
Well, why not?
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
Hat or hair?
Well, I think that hairstyle...
That one always has a hat.
Okay.
Let's try ponytail.
Ponytail.
Ponytail, ponytail.
Ghost laughter.
Yeah, that's the good stuff.
Let's see.
Ponytail.
One of the chosen few.
Oh, you scared me for a second.
You scared me.
No, there's no chosen few.
There have been.
All of them are chosen.
All of them.
Granny Ada Ada.
Okay, let's see.
Um, let's get...
Let's get Sniffloo right here.
Go ahead, go ahead.
I can't let you in.
That's so rude.
That's actually...
You can't just reject me for no reason.
Well, you're okay.
Everyone in this game...
is so superficial.
They all just judge on looks.
They judge on how our appearance.
It's so messed up.
I'm glad that it's just hair though.
It's pretty easy.
Okay, Dafferil.
Alrighty.
Look, Granny's got a harem.
Granny's got it going on.
You're sad.
You're a sad man.
What, do you want Frofa?
Uh-uh.
Okay, Frofa.
Try this way.
Oh my god.
Not all doors are open to you.
That's so rude.
Oh my gosh.
Granny's collecting them all.
Are you gonna have anyone?
Oh my god, he's so lonely.
Certainly.
He's just so grumpy.
I know.
It's so rude.
Alright, Rubricio.
I believe in you.
Someone.
Uh-uh.
Okay, hold on.
This one.
Okay, fine.
Not all doors are open to you.
Fine.
You deserve no one.
You know what?
You can live your sad, lonely life.
It's your fault.
You shut yourself out from the world.
You beg for touch.
But you're the one who doesn't allow it.
You beg for someone to love you.
Well, you're okay.
You wish that someone could just...
You wish that someone would just come in.
But you shut the door on everybody.
You tell him.
Emiano.
You're our last little guy.
I feel called out.
I feel attacked.
You've done quite well.
How delightful.
Thank you.
And so our brave travelers continue on through this dusty wasteland until they meet...
This is the best part.
Arno, the almost omnivorous, one very hungry pizza troll.
Yes!
Pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza!
Oh, fleas!
You're not!
Please!
Wherever you are.
Make me a pizza!
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so basically we have to make him a pizza.
And make it exactly as he likes.
We don't know what he likes.
So we just have to go combo by combo.
Let's do cheese.
Just cheese.
Cheese.
More toppings!
Okay, so if he throws it over here, that means he doesn't like any of the toppings.
But if he throws it over here, that means he'll still eat it.
So he does like the cheese.
More toppings!
Thank you!
Thank you for all the great past adventures here to Minnie Moore.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I was just trying to check out the stream on my break, but things got way too real, way too fast.
I'm so sorry.
I gotta keep it real.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
More toppings!
Let's just do mushrooms.
And eventually there's three guys.
Something must go!
Oh, he does not like the mushroom.
He's just like me.
Me for real, for real.
Okay.
I like when he says, there's something on that I don't like.
Please.
I kind of want to put in mushrooms again just so he says it.
There's stuff on that I don't like!
Oh, he says it a different way though.
He's so cute though.
The way his mouth is so like...
Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on, hold on.
I can do that.
I can do that too.
It's so...
There's something on that I don't like!
Okay.
Cheese, peppers.
Pineapple.
No.
Cheese, pineapple.
The goaded combination.
I know you love it, Trunkman.
I know you love it.
Thank you, thank you.
You did it!
You saved them all!
I saved them.
Somehow.
Good job, whoever you are.
Eventually, if you get it wrong enough times, they'll punch you and your little zumbinis will fly away.
Oh, a camp!
It's so good.
The music is so awesome.
Hold on.
What's this?
A campsite with hot soup all ready to eat?
For zumbinis to relax!
But when they're ready to move on, they'll need a group of 16 along the path.
16.
Yeah, so we have to keep our whole crew.
And this also boils.
I remember all the clicks.
Actually, that's the only two I...
Let's change it to green.
Like me.
Oh.
More mintings!
It's great seeing you be so passionate about the things you love.
Man, the audio of this game brings back so many memories of that era.
Now, we have to decide.
Which way do we go?
I'll be honest, I don't remember which one leads to which path.
So we have to make a decision.
Corn soup?
I wish.
I'll be honest, when I would see this as a kid, I used to think it was poison.
It doesn't look like a good soup.
Doesn't look...
I don't like that.
He sounds too close.
He sounds so like...
in my ear.
Didn't like that one.
This...
This one looks a little like it's got a butt cheek.
Okay, guys.
Let's make a poll.
When I click out of the game, you won't hear it anymore.
So, start a poll.
Which direction?
There's two.
I'm pretty sure there's another time when we get to choose.
So left, or I'll go up, down.
Check the map.
No, no!
We're adventurers!
We're adventuring!
We don't know what the road will go to!
It's all about the discovery, baby!
Down for down bad.
Team up.
Adventurers also check their maps.
No, they don't!
Not the zumbinis.
They are...
They are full of whimsy.
Okay.
All right.
It looks like it's up.
Let's go upward.
I think we're going through this game so quickly we'll be able to play again and we can go downwards next time.
Zumbinis must have something in common with their neighbor to sit on Captain Cajun's Ferry.
Oh my god.
It's so soulful.
Wow!
The art looks so good!
Welcome to the booth.
Now hurry yourselves up and find your seat.
Okay.
So, they have to have something in common.
This is easy.
Well, sit wherever you want to.
I don't really care.
Okay.
Ponytail.
This one's easy.
This one's so easy.
There you go.
You got it.
Everything's rushing back to me.
Even the things that I was like, oh, I don't really remember this part so much.
We'll go by eyes.
There you go.
You got it.
Well, first it...
I went eyes to hair.
Oops.
It's fine, though.
If we have to adjust anybody, we can do that.
There you go.
You got it.
Like we have to do right now.
Yep.
Hold on.
Okay.
There you go.
You got it.
Let's see.
I actually don't remember what happens if you put a wrong guy down.
Oh, dang.
Are you okay?
Let's see.
They have springs and they have sleepy eyes.
Hey, what?
What are you doing there?
Excuse me.
I need the sleepy eyes.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Blue nose is...
Hmm.
Here's the noses.
Yeah, let's go by noses instead.
We'll go by noses instead.
Shp.
Green.
There you go.
You got it.
Oh, I can't see.
Everybody separate.
Separate.
Stop being so close to each other.
Okay.
And then we'll go pink.
Pink nose.
I shouldn't have separated the...
Ah.
Sure.
Now red nose.
Now yellow nose.
But I'm probably gonna have to switch it again, I think.
Wait.
What do you have in... Oh, there we go.
Feet.
Oh.
There we go.
Ah.
Sure.
There you go.
You got it.
Oh, I'm done.
Mister.
Oh my god.
I could've left at any time.
I could've...
The frogs!
We could've just left them... There.
We could've just left them.
That's so sad.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
I love this one.
This one's so fun.
Okay, so each froggy has a pattern, right?
And you have to...
They can only go...
I don't... I think they can't go diagonal.
So they can only go... You have to drop them on the correct spot that gets them to the other side.
So, like, say, we go with the X guy.
But they can only be used a couple times.
Like, you can't say, like, oh, okay, let's have all 16 Zoombinis get on this one guy.
No, no, no.
Only, like, a certain amount.
So, it's like boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
No.
See, we can't go that way.
Let's see.
If we do boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
No.
Boom, boom.
Wait.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom.
Oh, I don't think we can use the X.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, next.
He...
I don't... I think he's out.
I think he's out.
Let's try... Oh!
And then there's also, like, the shape of the lily pad.
So, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, BOOM!
And they're very slow.
Where are you going?
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?!
Frog, Noooo!
How did
you do this?
Wait,
maybe he'll make it eventually.
Actually... Okay, okay, this time.
This is the run.
Thank you guys, thank you so much!
I always thought it was a shame that you didn't get to use this model much, so seeing you come back with updated rigging is awesome.
I'm so glad, thank you!
Yes.
Yes!
Okay, nice.
There we go.
It reminded... Oh my gosh.
You know what that reminded me of?
You know that video of the girl who's watching someone put the shapes in the holes?
And he's just like, this is a rectangle shape.
What shape does it go into?
And she's like, the rectangle.
And he's like, that's right, the circle hole.
Or the square hole.
And she's like, no, that's how I felt at that very moment.
Okay.
Do we put ourselves through... Actually, I just realized the yellow one is an absolute straight shot, so let's just...
There's no room for error here.
Yes.
Just go, go, go.
All the way.
Also, the blue one.
You can do multiples at a time, so...
There we go.
The pink one...
You can also go.
But you don't want them, like, running into each other.
So it's probably safer to do the colors together.
The teal one works too?
You're so right!
Oh my god, speedrun.
What about the red one?
Red also works!
Oh, there's...
Oh my god, frog mania.
Frog mania!
All the colors are good?
That's crazy.
Do you guys like this sound?
I hope they... I wish they would sink.
I don't think there's a way for them to sink, but if there were...
If there were a way, it would be really great.
Yes?
There's something about...
Old games that just have, like, that...
They just...
It's like...
Oh my gosh, have you guys ever listened to the Barbie movies?
Like, listen...
Just look up clips of the Barbie movies.
Like the...
The old, old ones.
You know, the animation ones.
And how...
How crisp her heels are on the ground.
Oh, actually, all of them...
All of them, like, walking just sounds so satisfying.
They just...
Oh, it sounds so good.
Okay.
Um...
Should we try this one again?
Let's get it going while we look for another pattern on, like, the other side.
I think.
X works too?
It does?
I thought we said it didn't.
Okay.
He's...
He's going.
Okay, let's try...
Um...
Oh, three leaf.
One.
Three.
Three, three, three, three.
Oh, that one works, actually.
Was it here?
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do.
Do.
Yep.
Nice.
Three leaf on the light blue.
Mint confirmed heel click fetish.
Is that a real fetish?
Actually?
Oh.
He messed up.
Oh, he messed up again.
Okay, I don't think we're gonna use you anymore.
I think you'll just get...
You'll get a little too confused, mister.
Okay, again.
If you have to ask.
I learned the other day that, um, stepping on stuff is a fetish, too.
I didn't know.
Like, someone would be like, oh, I'm...
Oh, no, I stepped on a slice of bread.
I didn't know.
But I just...
I just wonder what's the...
What is the...
Oh, okay.
He's gone now.
Like, what gets you going about that?
Well, maybe crushing.
I kind of...
I mean, I don't know.
Maybe I do get it.
Maybe I learned just now.
Maybe I understood in this very moment.
Okay.
Anyway.
Let's see.
Uh, we have this pattern as well.
Oh, no.
Uh, no.
Hmm.
What else?
We got diamonds.
Hmm.
No.
We got flowers.
Four leaf.
No.
Okay.
So, it has to be this one, right?
The yellow X.
This one?
Oh.
Wait.
Ah.
Oh, he's going to get just as confused as I am.
He's going to get just as confused as I am.
IDK.
I'm watching at 144p.
Is it for the true, like, 90s...
Like, um, 90s game experience?
Aesthetic?
Oh.
He did it.
He's a smart frog.
You're a smart frog.
You are.
How do these guys live?
Nice.
Okay.
Last one.
Yeah, I never played Putt-Putt.
I only played one game of Freddy Fish.
And this.
I played Myst a little bit.
Did I understand Myst?
No.
But I played it.
I played...
Well, I would...
I would watch my dad play Diablo.
And never Winter Nights.
Beem.
Myst, my beloved.
Okay.
Thank you for the...
Oh, no.
Did it?
This is...
Oh, I remember this one.
I remember really liking the sounds in this puzzle.
Gosh, I love the frog ones so much.
Okay.
So, this one, you just have to not be lonely.
Actually, this works.
This works perfectly because I only have two people.
Oh, just kidding.
Um...
What do I do with him?
Well, I failed.
No.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Lato.
Sni-Flu.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
Sni-Flu.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to burn your butt.
I didn't mean to burn your butt like that.
Zafiro.
I love the crunchy sounds so much.
We have one Cyclops.
Two Cyclops.
Okay.
That one actually...
Shit.
Um...
Feet.
This one...
Oh.
This one also works.
All you have to do is have eyebrows.
Oh.
Eyeballs, I guess.
Um...
Oh!
Wait.
I just realized...
Oh.
I'm an idiot.
It's the same feet...
Oh.
Okay.
You guys...
Children's game.
This game's not outsmarting me, okay?
This game is not outsmarting me.
Okay.
We need...
Maybe...
Then...
Okay.
Not the hair.
For...
Well...
Okay.
You can be matched with someone else, though.
You can have the same feet...
As him.
You can have the same nose...
And...
You guys can have the same hair.
But then we need...
Hmm...
It's just the right difficulty.
Okay.
Let's...
Hmm...
Same hair.
They don't have the same feet.
They don't have...
Do I have another rollie?
Her.
Hmm...
Can I switch around?
Who can I switch around?
Blah.
Glasses.
Bottom right has the same hair.
That's true.
That is...
Yeah.
That's true.
But...
They also have the same feet.
Wait.
So...
If I...
Can...
Move...
Someone...
Okay.
Hold on.
We...
Rollie?
But they don't have the same nose.
But they...
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh!
Sorry.
Okay.
And then...
We gotta make this possible, you guys.
Okay.
You...
You guys have the same eyes.
So we'll take...
Hold on.
I'm just...
Same eyes.
Wait.
What do you guys have?
You guys have the same eyes, too.
But you don't have the same feet!
Wait.
I had it?
Oh.
What did I do?
Okay.
Wait.
I had it?
I did?
Where?
No.
I...
Oh.
Same feet.
Oh!
You're right.
Same eyes.
You got them all through!
Good for you!
Remember at the beginning when I was like, we need a lot of variety?
It's puzzles like this.
Yay!
Oh!
You can leave without them.
It's kind of sad, though.
Flute goes hard.
Yeah.
You can leave without all of them.
It's so sad.
Mii-Win Pattern Recognition.
Indeed!
Another relaxing campsite ready and waiting for Zoombinis!
They'll meet at the rest.
The darkest, most mysterious places in the world.
I think we avoided the forest of the guys that are actually trying to kill us.
So that's good.
I love this guy.
He loves his job.
Are there any other clickables?
Hey, that's just the same sound effect from the... Oh.
I do remember those.
Eww!
This game is so goofy.
Wait, so now we're at the lions.
We have the lions.
We have the crystals.
We have another face matching game.
I think that's it.
Yeah, the bubbles.
The bubbles.
The bubbles is the... What's it called?
I think that I called it... Wait.
I don't remember this one.
Oh!
I have to go in order of their nose.
Oh, okay.
That's easy.
Blue.
Green.
Do they have to have something similar though?
Oh, I guess they do.
What the...
Wait, so they have to have...
Oh, sorry.
I just... For some reason I was only looking at the eyes.
Okay, hold on.
Oh no.
It's like the same thing.
I missed the blue?
Oh, I did.
You're so right.
Thank you.
I didn't even see it because it was partially hidden.
Alright, so green...
Green.
Oh, I only have two left.
I'm throwing, you guys.
I'm throwing for real.
When it comes to red...
Yeah, we can do this guy.
And then this guy.
I don't know if there has to be a similar thing to the previous person, but we'll just do it anyway.
Red.
Splendid job!
Thank you, narrator!
I'm so smart!
What are you throwing?
The ball...
The ball in your court.
Oh my gosh, I love the sounds in this one too.
This one's fun.
All of them are fun.
I felt like that lion one was a little too easy though, right?
So just be... Wow!
It looks so fancy now!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, so...
Look.
We have to match...
The reflection.
Wait, but this is exactly them!
Can I just put another guy on here?
But...
Wait, so if I do... Hold on.
If I... Is it... If I combine?
Or do I have to have the same...
Same person?
No, I have to combine, right?
So we need a Cyclops with blue...
Nose.
Do we even have that?
No.
Wait, I actually don't remember this one.
Match the characters, pull the lever.
Do they change each time?
Why is there a second seat?
Wait!
Oh, it does refresh!
Wait, it did?
I don't remember.
I don't remember this one at all.
I remember it, but I don't remember it.
Why is there a second seat?
I think...
Maybe for...
When you go through it again...
Is what I'm thinking of.
I think...
Like round two.
Right?
Bing!
It refreshes every two zoomings.
Okay, okay.
So who's...
This is our guy.
The sound reminds me of the Indiana Jones ride.
Nice.
Who's our next victim?
This guy.
What's your name?
Muscus.
I'm Paco.
Paco?
No.
Um...
him.
Whoa...
Try putting two on?
It wouldn't...
It won't let me.
I've tried.
Who is... the next... you...
Like it won't even let me drag... it won't even let me pick them up.
I think it's for... I think it's for a future... future playthroughs.
Because the puzzles do get like a... not more difficult, but...
Well, I guess maybe it is a little bit more difficult.
They realize you level up as a gamer.
You know?
I'll show you what happens when you get one wrong though.
It's so sad.
All the
other puzzles give you...
I don't even know her name.
I killed her in cold blood.
I didn't even know her name.
All
the other puzzles give me like a leeway.
This one's just like, no, it's too easy.
You need to know immediately.
Oh my god.
It's so...
We killed her, you guys.
We killed her.
You're accomplices now.
You also killed her with me.
It is not just me.
It is a we.
This is us.
We are in this together, okay?
I knew you guys were gonna be like, we?
Yes, we!
We!
I just got here.
I'm so shocked right now.
Because I've been showing you guys like kind of what happens when you miss the other ones.
The frog one too?
If you mess up on the frog one, the frogs just jump forever.
Like they just don't move.
Like your zumbinis don't die.
They're just stuck in this never-ending like...
It's kind of...
It's not kind of.
It's really messed up.
Oh my gosh.
Can you charge a ghost with murder?
The game gets harder the more zumbinis you save when you do New Game Plus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I do remember.
Yeah, it may be we, but we'll get less time in the pen if we turn state's...
If we turn state's evidence.
Wait.
No, no, no.
No, no.
No, there is no evidence.
There's no evidence that the VOD is gone.
Alrighty, buddy.
You're our last one.
Yay, we all survived.
We all.
We all survived.
Bubbles.
This one's fun too.
They're all fun.
This one's fun.
It's always been 15.
Woah.
Dun, dun, dun, dun.
I don't remember what this means.
Oh.
That's a hairstyle.
Okay, so if it's...
Okay, so hairstyle man.
This guy has to go on this one.
Because otherwise he's going to...
He's going to get eaten.
So musk goose.
Go, Maskus.
Go.
And go, Kaislu.
Go, my children.
Frofa.
Leave you to... Maybe I should have... Well, we know it's going to be fine.
We know it's going to be fine.
I was going to say, maybe I should have let just one guy go and tested it before I let all of them go, but, you know.
Arigato, arigato.
Chuu.
Okay.
Now, sad eye.
I won't let you go.
Rubrisco.
Oh.
Girl, I'm working towards my Master's in Criminal Psychology.
You were sort of giving me content to feed to add to a report I'm doing.
Watching VTubers is educational, you guys.
Didn't you know?
Okay.
He goes... I'll go that way.
Yeah, he's fine.
We just have to... Oh.
Maybe I should have done a glasses.
Okay.
This time, I'm going to do this glasses.
I know, Chuu.
We're going to have to switch between the two.
Yeah, we'll alternate.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So now, it's a cool glasses.
Denise!
Oh my god.
At least Denise is alive, right?
Okay.
Now, glasses.
Oh my god.
It's so crunchy.
Okay.
Now, sunglasses.
Now, glasses.
Now,
sunglasses.
And now, everybody else.
Wait.
Isn't Kay... Isn't she the one that fell down the hole?
She's alive!
You guys, she's alive!
She's the one that fell down!
We're fine!
How do I play this?
On Steam.
Everything's all good.
Yippee!
I know.
Thank you, narrator!
Wait.
Was that the last one?
I don't remember anyone after this.
Have we reached the Promised Land?
One.
Two.
Three.
Oh, whoops.
Sorry.
Oh!
No!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
It's okay.
We'll just have to play again.
We have...
A wind bill.
This wind bill was wrought to honor the Zumbinis who calmed Captain Cajun, rode tattooed toads, and knew how to network.
When the traveling was not so easy.
Today.
Look at our guys!
Katie...
This clock tower was constructed for the Zumbinis who ambled past allergic cliffs, cruised on by stone-cold caves, and appeased Arno, the almost omnivorous.
Who are these people?
I'm gonna show you!
I'm gonna talk to you!
All right.
Let's get it started!
Oh!
Oh my god!
I love the sound of this!
I love it so much!
Oh, it's so good!
You can practice the music, guys.
Spoilers, spoilers, spoilers.
You can also practice some of the levels that are on different difficulties too.
What?
That's so cool.
Very, very hard.
Wow.
Oh, so hard.
So that's why I said not so easy.
Because we were on the easy level.
See, and we have...
16.
We still have 384.
Is that what that means?
Wait.
She's here!
You guys, she is alive.
Rebro!
She's right there!
See?
She's alive.
Man.
She lives.
We're fine.
Oh, okay.
My bad.
The big, the bad, and the hungry.
So now we're gonna go to the campsite.
I thought there was another...
Split, but I guess there's just the one.
So we have a whole other set of puzzles down here.
Isn't that so exciting?
Scrooge!
Scrooge must live at all costs, you guys.
If anything happens to Scrooge, I'm gonna cry.
Oh, you are too similar.
Ape.
You're also similar.
Rhian.
Oh, I think it...
Zagla.
Yeah.
Cool deal.
So prude.
Daiso!
You're back!
Oh my gosh, you guys!
We got Daiso back!
Let's go!
Scrooge.
Aflok.
Leleblir.
Adrawee.
Ruhwabu.
What am I missing?
We have no...
Skates.
Macy.
Doku.
No, we need skates.
I read...
I read this wrong, I think.
Hi, Aura?
Oh my god!
Hello!
I played this when I was a kid.
Me too.
Hello, hello, hello.
Thanks for dropping by!
What else am I missing?
We have...
We need more pony tail.
Bos... Boswasku.
I don't know the name of the game.
I'm gonna have to find another one.
You know what, hard mode.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I thought it was just the one guy.
It's gonna be like...
Hard mode!
We won't decide them at all!
And if it was just one man that walked out...
it would be so funny...
A very long sermon.
I would always do the frog one.
So, I'll be honest, I don't remember the second route so much.
I remember the hotel one, but I don't... Oh, and the forest where they're trying to kill us.
I don't remember anything.
I don't know.
I don't remember the other ones.
Fleece!
We're not Fleece!
Okay.
Is it glasses?
No glasses again?
It wouldn't be so simple, right?
Wait, are we on easy mode again still?
I don't know.
We're not glasses.
I said glasses, no glasses.
It was eye... Oh!
Okay.
It's not the hair.
But they have nothing else in common.
This guy is like almost an identical twin, so...
Okay.
Doesn't help us so much.
Thanks for the dough and all.
After trying to win a cinema role for over an hour in a UFO catcher crane game, I finally made it for Zoombini's nostalgia time.
I don't blame you.
I'm so bad at crane games though.
Oh!
Do you guys mind if I have a snack?
I... Oh my gosh.
At... at the airport when I was coming home, they sometimes have like these pop-up stores that like sell little snacks that you can... that you can get.
And this one was called the Butter Butler.
And it's a fancier little butter cake.
It's so...
Butter Finacier.
Butter Butler.
Oh, that's just his butter butler.
Finas... Fin... Finacier.
Fin... Fin... Fin... Fin... Fin... Fin... Financiers.
The butter fanciers.
And they're so good.
It's like a little...
I'm just smelling it right now.
It smells like...
It smells like a butter... like a waffle.
Like when you put butter on a waffle.
Oh, it smells so good.
If you can look up the Butter Butler.
It's so yummy.
It's so good.
Okay.
Let's try eyes.
Trying her.
Okay.
Trying you.
Daiso.
Don't let us down, Daiso.
Very good, Daiso.
Okay.
That sounds good.
It's really good.
Okay.
We got through all the ones that we were sure of.
What about you?
No.
Mm -hmm.
Mm-hmm.
You.
He's allergic to... he's allergic to nerds for real.
You like glasses though.
You're a man of culture.
What about you?
Huh?
What?
Not the... you're even allergic to... to... Cyclops?
It's so sad.
You have no culture.
Splendid job!
Are these noses?
I just... I can't tell.
Hmm.
These stone guards have their rules, so do proceed with skill.
Zumbini's one guard won't allow.
The other guard surely will.
Splendid!
Strange looking bunch!
Where do they all come from?
Sorry, we just keep passing through.
Alright.
Is he going to be so sad this time?
Can't let you in.
Why not?
Why?
Like, I need... come on.
Sure.
Okay,
let's try the glasses.
Enjoy yourself.
I mean... what?
He has friends now.
Maybe this... he had a change of heart.
Is it glasses?
Is he a glasses enjoyer?
Hello.
Oh my gosh.
Hello, Mr. Stone.
Wow.
Don't mind if I do.
Yeah.
Okay, well that's all the glasses we got.
Let's try...
Wait, that means...
We must be selective about our clientele.
What does that mean?
What's wrong with A-Floke?
Huh?
I think you're just being very discriminatory.
Don't be shy.
Kinda.
I think I'm... I think I'm... I think I like the... the rock.
I think I'm like... like wow for this...
Okay.
Have a good time.
Thank you.
I mean, he's just got a bit of a career... I think I misjudged him before.
You know?
Oh.
Nope.
So it's hair.
It's not the eyes.
Interesting.
Go ahead.
Enjoy yourself.
Yeah.
Okay, so it's the hair instead.
So these guys messy hair and ponytail.
Messy hair or...
Sure.
I don't... I don't even know what to call that.
A single strand.
Hello.
When can we start sending the Akasupas?
Why are you so eager to do that?
But also I think it might be...
You'll do.
Get right up.
I think it might be a little while because YouTube says that I need more watch hours.
So even after today's stream, I'm not so sure.
Okay.
So Prue?
Wait.
And so these are the guys too.
Daiso?
Welcome.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
He's just got so much charisma.
You know?
Sure.
Thank you, sir.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
It's literally the opposite.
Hello.
It's the opposite of last time.
Okay.
By me.
Don't be shy.
Sure.
Okay.
It's the other side.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Okay.
Hip hip zumbini!
I love... I love the...
Okay.
This is the cool kids club.
Look how cool they look.
And this is everybody else.
The narrator is the best guy ever.
Hip hip zumbini!
And so our brave travelers continue on through this dusty wasteland...
I'm so excited.
...until they meet...
What the hell just happened?
...Arno, the almost omni...
...pulverous...
...one very hungry pizza troll.
One hungry pizza troll.
Fleens?
You're not fleens.
I think we're still on easy mode.
Whatever you are.
Make me a pizza!
Okay.
Oh, it's up to you, buddy.
All right.
We're gonna go down the line.
Actually, we're gonna... we're gonna make this a little interesting.
You know, we're gonna try two combos at once.
Something on that I don't like.
Sometimes he will actually just get, like, a plain ass...
...like, no cheese pizza.
He said the thing!
More!
Okay.
He's begging for it.
Sorry, mister.
Okay, so he doesn't like mushrooms.
More!
That's how you... That's how you really get the girls, you know?
I'm supposed to be working, but this child's game is too engaging.
Go work!
Okay.
Bellbackers.
Wow!
Only three tries!
I think we're a genius.
Thank you.
Oh, sorry narrator.
Ah, base camp one.
What's this?
Okay, bye-bye.
Nope.
We are no time to stop, Zoobinis.
No, no rest.
No rest allowed.
The fleens are the guys actually trying to kill us.
The fleens?
These guys.
These guys are actually trying to kill us.
Okay, so you have to put a guy out and have... I don't remember how this one goes.
I think certain traits a Zoobini has will have a certain guy jump off.
But you need these guys to jump... I don't remember how this one... wait, hold on.
There's no sense leaving it up to chance.
Lure the fleens off the tree branch.
Oh yeah, we are not so easy.
Feeling stuck?
Wait, no.
No, we're gonna get this ourselves.
We don't... we don't... I'm sorry, I didn't read it.
You are fleens.
No, we're not.
The tree guy just said fleens.
You're not fleens.
We're Zoobinis.
We're not the fleens.
These are the fleens.
They are so high tech for like...
Is this... is this Metal Gear?
I like that sound.
Man, I hated this one.
I don't remember how it works, so...
No, no, Skrookey.
Skrookey, get behind me.
Skrookey, get behind...
Skrookey, stay back there.
Okay, we're gonna get a Floak.
Okay, so basically we only have a couple chances because they're gonna slide eventually and fall off the thing.
So...
Maybe...
It was either her glasses or the color of her nose or...
Okay, so aggressive.
I know the fleens are crazy.
Let's try one completely different.
Robo...
Okay...
The hair is correct.
The hair was correct, yes.
Oh!
Okay.
So we need...
You.
Like that.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
So...
We need...
No.
No, no, Skrookey.
No, no, no.
I won't allow it.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh, that's right.
Wait, how am I supposed to get the...
No, Skrookey.
No, no, Skrookey.
Daiso!
Oh!
Skrookey, no!
Yeah, because it's the same legs.
Oh my god.
Skrookey.
Skrookey has to go.
He's looking around.
He doesn't even want to look at me.
He's so scared.
He's like, Mom!
Mom, what are you picking me up for?
Mom, why are you leading me over into the danger zone?
Mom!
Mom, I'm scared!
No, can I?
Oh, I'm trying to pull back.
Oh, Mom, no, please!
Please, Mom, you said you would protect me!
Scroogey!
Here comes the awesome music, yeah!
Yeah!
All right, Scroogey in the lead!
Nice!
Hurry, Zumpinis!
Ula, the forest's foremost, and perhaps only, band leader!
Is about to begin rehearsals!
She'll be closing the hotel for the night, so scamper into a room!
Okay.
We believe in Scroogey, yeah.
I don't remember how this works.
Yes?
Ah, yes!
I'll be right down.
Make yourselves cozy.
Yeah, but you're also picky.
Just when I was starting rehearsal...
Welcome!
You're just in time for tomorrow's concerto!
Okay.
Help yourselves.
Help yourselves to a room.
Okay.
I got rehearsal.
Go ahead.
Find yourselves a room.
Where did she go?
Why has she talked over herself, even?
Hmm.
I'm glad I got to see you again.
Thank you so much for the live stream!
Thank you for watching!
Hmm.
Okay, so...
All
right?
All right.
Oh, my God.
Who's sharing a room with Scroogey tonight?
Oh, and we do have like a kind of...
That clock is terrifying.
Oh, my gosh.
The clock is giving like over the garden wall vibes.
It's so scary.
Let's put you over here.
Oh, is it the eyes?
Okay.
I don't remember what... is it the eyes?
Is it eyes?
Is it just eyes?
Is that it?
Is it so simple?
Am I overthinking it?
As I do with everything?
I think so.
Because there's only this...
Yeah, there's only five slides.
I guess I could have made it anything.
Maybe.
I could have made it eyes.
I could have made it hair.
Oops, I made it hair.
Sorry, I might have said hair and so I put it in there.
Oh, Rhiann is all by themselves.
Sorry.
Oh my god, it's spooky.
See you in the morning.
This is the paint splatter one!
Strike the targets one and all and watch for a pattern on Mudball Wall.
Mudball Wall.
Best minigame?
You guys like this one?
The sounds in this one are immaculate.
Oh!
Did you hear that?
My god, it's so good.
Wait, I don't remember how to do this one though.
Wait, I don't remember how this one works.
So we pick a color.
Oh my god!
And we pick a shape.
And we have to hit like here.
Right?
I hate it so much.
Really?
You don't like it?
I kind of love it.
I don't remember.
Okay, so we'll figure out.
Let's see.
Red.
Nice!
Okay, so this is the star area.
Is this triangle?
Let's just try it.
No.
And also we need to figure out what this row is.
Oh!
Okay.
So it's yellow something.
Yellow square.
I'm calling it now.
For the three.
Or this three.
Never mind.
Oh wait, we could do diamond.
Nice.
Alright.
Get in there guys.
Hurry up.
Time is money.
Of the demo I played as a kid, this was my favorite.
They had a demo of this?
Nice.
I love how conflicted the chat is on on these these sounds.
It's so funny.
Okay, I think we can we basically have all the information we need to to complete this.
Piece of cake, baby!
Well, except for this one.
Everything else piece of cake.
I have no idea how this works.
Okay.
So each row is a color.
And each column is a shape.
So you just have to see these are star shapes.
These are triangle shapes.
See?
Let's try green.
I don't know.
I'm feeling green.
Oh.
Okay.
This is a wild guess.
I think I'm getting a wild streak.
Like a little wild hair.
I think it might be pink.
Genius.
Nailed it.
And look.
And you run out of ink.
See here?
You can run out.
So...
It could be... Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine if Skrookey was left behind?
I don't even want to think about the thought.
Yay!
Well done, oh wise and trusted guide.
Thank you.
I'm wise and trusted.
You guys.
How do you get ink refills?
You don't.
You run out of ink, you just have to leave them behind.
This goes so hard.
Amazing indeed.
Another relaxing She's gonna have to stay here.
campsite ready and waiting for Zumbinis.
She's...
And they'll need their rest.
She's uh...
She's watching over the camp, you know?
The journey is yet to come!
Swap her in.
Nah, she's good.
Throughout these gloomy mountains, strange carvings left by ancient peoples are everywhere.
Spooky.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, next time we play this, we're gonna go on hard.
Should we?
We'll just go on the hardest mode, I think.
Oh!
What the heck is that?
Those are the hair!
Okay.
So it's like this hair...
We have a lot of these guys.
We have so many single hairs.
And then ponytail.
Right?
That is a pony.
And this is the high.
Okay.
We have one pony...
Oh!
Two ponytails.
And we have...
Actually, I wanna see...
Oh!
They don't need to be...
connected to one another.
To one another.
So that makes things so much easier.
I was making things more difficult on myself.
Than it really needed to be.
I think you all know who's gonna be in the front.
Our man, Skrookey.
Wait.
His name is Skrookey?
I thought his name was Skrookey.
It's Skrookey this whole time?
You lied to me?
I thought it was Skrookey.
What?
Just Skrookey?
She finally noticed.
It's been his reflection.
It will give them crystal-slamming protection.
Let's just pretend he's still Skrookey.
Girl boss gaslit herself.
I can't believe!
I cannot believe that I just...
That I just made that up.
I stole their identi- Like I stole...
This whole time they probably just like...
She can't even get my name right.
Gosh this mid-girl sucks.
She can't even...
She can't even read.
Sorry.
Yeah, he's still Skrookey in our hearts.
Right guys?
Skrookey.
Literacy is overrated.
True.
So true bestie.
Hmm...
Skrookey in the streets.
Skrookey in the sheets.
He did have that- Wait we need to ask Who is- Her?
Coldio.
How was he in the hotel room, I wonder.
Thanks for the donut!
Edutainment gives proving its value by finally teaching victory.
Just noticed that you had a messy... Sorry, I missed this one earlier, AJ.
You have messy hair, sunglasses, red nose, spring Zumbini in your party.
This one?
That combo was always my favorite as a kid.
I think his name was Edawanka.
You even remember his name!
Wow, true Zumbini fan.
My favorite combo was glasses and this hair and the...
Either the roller skates or the...
Or the...
Two wheels like that.
That was my favorite combo.
Because I always thought it looked like me.
You finally acknowledge me after all this time.
Tsuruki, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Favorite hair color?
You can't change the hair color.
Right?
Oh, it's your favorite.
Oh, nose color.
Oh, it was blue.
It was blue.
Why does this get more difficult for me the less Zumbinis I have?
Why can't I find him?
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
Hip hip Zumbini.
This is so funny.
Beady eyes.
Little beady guy.
I don't remember this eye style in the original.
Why is the narrator so awesome?
He's so funny.
He's like...
He's kind of like... if the guy from the Stanley Parable was in a good game.
And like happy about it, you know?
Not to say... wait, that makes it sound like the Stanley Parable is not a good game.
Oh wait, I was right.
It is a good game.
Sorry, it is a good game.
You know what I mean?
It just makes me feel like he's like...
Oh yeah, I'm enjoying my life now.
I hate the Stanley Parable.
I should play it.
The last time I tried playing it, the game crashed on me.
So I never actually got to beat it.
Search first for traps.
So easy to miss.
To get Zoombinis across Bubble Wonder Abyss.
Thanks for the donut.
When I was a kid, my mom would buy these big styrofoam eggs from the craft store.
And I'd paint them blue and decorate them like Zoombinis.
We found one under the porch when my parents moved from a family home.
And when they retired 30 years later.
Oh my gosh.
That's insane.
Wait, this is the same exact pattern as before.
Okay, so all our scruffy heads.
Scruffy.
I'm gonna turn this one down because it does hurt.
Alright, first.
Ponytail.
Right?
She goes...
Yeah.
Yeah, ponytail first.
Ponytail.
Wait.
Uh oh.
Wait, uh oh.
Well, the scruffies have to go this way.
Because if they go this way, they will immediately go in.
So they have to go the other way.
But uh oh.
We have a lot of single men.
I think it'll work out.
Oh!
We do have another ponytail!
We do have another ponytail.
Okay.
I missed you, Apu.
I think I've missed you several times.
My bad.
Thanks for the... No!
Happy to see you streaming again.
Thank you so much!
Okay.
Ibleble.
Go Ibleble.
Okay.
We're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
I'm single by choice.
Yeah.
You...
Last,
but not least.
Soul Proof.
I'm single by choice.
Not mine.
Oh!
Don't worry about it.
Being single is fine, you know?
It's fine, too.
Right?
I did.
Good for me!
Thanks, narrator.
Prosperity.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I deprived you of that magnificent performance originally.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, we got a school!
And little houses!
A schoolhouse.
So it's the Zimbanis who flushed the finicky fleens in Hotel Dementia?
Had pleasant dreams and catapulted cleanly over Mudball Wall.
What else?
What's this one?
This bowling alley honors...
I love how we just escaped, like, this terrible situation that the Zimbanis are in.
And their first thought is just like, Yeah, we need a bowling alley.
Like...
Maybe a supermarket.
Like, you guys gotta eat.
Nah, bowling alley.
Did not lag in Lion's Lair, solved the secrets of the mirror machine, and flew above Bubble Wonder Abyss.
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Really appreciate it.
Hope you had a good stream.
Thank you!
We're playing Zimbanis.
So the Zimbanis finally reached their new home.
They established a nation of Zimbanis.
Four Zimbanis.
This independent nation would later be known to...
Very nice, isn't it?
But don't you have a job to do?
Zimbanis to free?
Did he just say, this is good, isn't it?
You can't just say that in front of me.
Alright, guys.
How do I change the difficulty?
How do I make it more difficult?
Options?
No...
Oh, we have on-screen captions?
Should have done that before.
Hmm...
Do I have to do it on practice?
Very, very hard.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I don't think I've ever done it this hard before.
Okay.
Now we're doing difficult mode.
We don't know a single...
We can't, we can't, we can't cater to our...
Actually, hold on.
I'll make my favorite though.
There we go.
Okay, the rest are all random.
There they...
Why do they all look the same?
Okay, stop it.
Can't remember a single day in Hotel Dementia for some reason.
Go for it.
I believe in you, Mint.
Okay.
Let's go.
I didn't change it.
Wait.
What do you mean I didn't change it?
See, it's on very hard.
Oh, but here...
See, it won't let me change it.
I'm clicking, I'm clicking, but it won't let me change it.
Sorry, sorry.
I didn't mean to abandon you guys.
Okay.
How am I supposed to change it?
Oh, they level up the more you do it.
So, this is just me practicing the each one.
Okay.
I get it.
I have to grind to get the very, very hard.
I'm so curious though.
How is it so hard on the pizza one?
Okay, let's just do the...
Pizza for lunch and snack and dinner and dessert, baby, would satisfy me.
Pizza time.
Okay.
Satisfy me.
So, let's look at what's NG.
There has... there is no ice cream.
Okay.
Ice cream by itself is NG.
So, it's got to be chocolate ice cream.
It's got to be chocolate ice cream.
Cheese.
Doesn't like mushrooms.
Here, let's just try a bell pepper.
Make me a pizza.
Something Moscow.
Oh, okay.
That topping, not for meatbags.
Not for meatbags.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Maybe it's not even the cheese.
They don't all like the same thing.
There's stuff on that I don't like.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
That topping, no.
Uh-oh.
I feel so much pressure right now.
Okay.
So, maybe it... Okay.
Just the pineapple?
Don't kick him out.
More!
That topping, not for meatbags.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
So, it's probably...
So, she doesn't like pineapple at all.
Wait.
So, maybe...
Can I do like a pineapple like sausage?
Oh, no!
I forgot the chocolate!
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
There's stuff on that I don't like.
Why do you not like the vanilla ice cream by itself but you're fine with it with chocolate?
Something's wrong.
Okay.
He didn't like the peppers.
No.
I don't think he liked the cheese.
Something must go.
There's something there I won't eat.
What?
Uh-oh.
There's something on that I don't want.
The guy... The guy on the right looks like he would like put his fingers together and be like, Ooh.
Sorry.
Ooh.
Maybe it's sausage.
Just peppers, I think?
No, but he liked the pineapple.
He didn't like just the peppers, right?
We tried that.
No pineapple, but he... This guy likes the pineapple.
She doesn't like pineapple.
I think.
Some of those toppings are distasteful.
Don't punch him.
Gee, I wasn't expecting that one.
Gee.
Don't punch him.
Okay.
More toppings.
That topping?
No.
Something on that's not good for me.
Don't punch him.
Okay.
They're so mean.
This.
This is his combo.
Right?
Has to be.
He said more toppings.
Please.
Something on that I don't like.
I don't get it.
What do you mean I don't like it?
That topping...
You wanted more!
He hates the cheese.
Uh-oh.
I think we're...
Wait,
can the dessert be...
Oh, it can be combined too!
Okay, so I think he likes the pizza.
As is.
Maybe he wants this.
Because this is bad.
Right?
What?
Oh my god, he's gonna get punched.
It's kind of funny to watch him.
Oh,
it's so good.
Is this it?
Okay, we got one.
This guy is so ridiculous.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so we know she doesn't like a pizza...
Not pizza.
She doesn't like the pineapple.
This thing is gonna be so full by the end.
Oh my gosh, it's tricky with having so many different types of toppings.
Well, they weren't kidding when they said very, very hard.
It is so hard.
Mm-hmm.
So...
Let's see.
I don't remember which ones are my creations and which one are...
I don't know.
The graveyard of lost pizzas.
I know.
Hmm.
Just plain everything.
I know, right?
What do you like?
Just...
I'm just gonna try it because I don't know what her opinion is on the peppers.
Some of those toppings are distasteful.
Distasteful.
It's still missing my favorites.
Okay, so he likes the peppers.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
What didn't he like?
Oh gosh, I was only paying attention to him.
Maybe this.
You like that?
This isn't about you!
We're going through them pretty quickly now.
Oh gosh!
Okay, so...
I can't remember what his opinion was on this one.
I don't know.
Do any of them like cheese?
Let's try this.
Do you like cheese, mister?
Do you like cheese?
Ah!
I don't care!
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Thank God this is just practice.
They're getting massacred.
This is so sad.
Do you want a little topping?
Do you want that?
This is making me want pizza.
Something's wrong.
What the?
The way he says it kind of annoys me.
What do you guys think?
What would you...
What do you...
What are your ideas?
Sounds like he's mocking her.
I know, right?
Something's wrong, Sprinkles.
Sprinkles.
I don't know.
I think I just gave him that one, right?
That topping?
No.
Uh-oh.
Someone says mushroom is missing.
Does he like mushroom?
Let's just try it.
Something's wrong.
For me?
Oh!
Nice!
Oh my gosh!
You were so right!
Good job.
Okay.
She hates everything.
I honestly have no idea what she wants.
Like, do you want just a plain pizza?
I don't understand what she wants.
An empty.
Give her a whole plain.
All right.
This one's for you.
So carefully.
Oh!
She's so crafty.
Is that all I get?
Yes!
Because you don't like anything else!
So she hates pineapple.
She hates peppers.
Maybe just cheese.
Just cheese.
Let's try just cheese.
There's something there I hate.
Oh my god!
It's a pizza!
It's just a pizza!
My god!
She hates cheese!
This is ridiculous.
I don't even know.
Just this?
Just give her the...
Yeah.
Is this all you want?
You want your...
No way!
What!
My friends, I'm sorry.
My friends would make their way back to safety.
She just got like a soup.
The intrepid ban continues.
Bravely onward.
Oh my gosh.
We made it through though.
I...
What?
Psychopath behavior right there.
Wow.
That one was really tricky though.
It was fun.
Let's try something else.
Let's try another one.
Let's try the frogs.
Frogs.
I do remember the fairy.
I do remember.
But I don't re...
What's that thing?
I...
Oh.
What is that thing?
What are you doing?
Oh.
I think I need to hurry.
Wait.
What is that thing?
Ah!
What's it doing?
Oh no.
I think it found the key.
We found the path and now it's taking over it.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, but they leave.
I don't know what the magic wand does.
The pink unfortunately does not work.
Blue... does not work.
Red... does not work.
Yellow... does not work.
These things are so annoying!
Try it out.
Oh wait, maybe it will...
What was one that was close?
This one?
Oh my
god, hurry!
Hurry!
Oh, we're fine.
Go!
This game is so...
It's so souls-like.
No!
Oh my gosh.
No, please.
It's over.
No!
Oh no!
Oh!
He's following us!
Ew, he's creepy!
Creepy!
Uh-oh.
Wait, what's going to happen with them?
No!
Okay, no...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
It worked!
It ended up working out!
We got so lucky.
Wait, so with the magic wand, can I like...
Like, say if I want to move this one and this one.
Oh, I can!
Interesting.
There's a little...
I think...
I see like the magic running out.
Why does that Zumbini look weird?
I guess they all kind of look weird.
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Why does he Fortnite dance?
Because he's excited.
Let him do his thing.
Bing!
Don't judge!
Oh.
I can also make the yellows work.
Bing!
Yellow.
What exactly is the puzzle here?
Okay.
So there's multiple types of paths that you can do.
Depending on what the frog is, right?
So the first one is by color.
The second is by the shape of the lily pad.
See?
Four.
Moon.
I gotta get moon.
And the third is the type of the flower that's on the lily pad.
Moon, moon.
There's just so much info on the screen right now.
I think that's why I like this one so much.
There's so much that you can, like, look at.
I hate these things.
I've never seen these before.
Clearly, I suck at the game as a child because I never got this far.
Uh-oh.
Agh!
No.
Oh, no.
Oh no.
Oh no no no.
Oh no no no no no.
Oh no.
A traffic jam!
These ones like- these guys are blocked up too!
They're blocking the blue path that I just made.
Plus, it's really peaceful.
Uh-oh.
Guys?
Do I even have enough magic to finish the path for them?
They get clogged here.
Oh, it stops it.
Let's just do...
this one.
Goodbye!
Sayonara!
There they go!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Wait, why are you going back?
Okay, yeah?
Move.
Oh my god.
You're supposed to go forward!
It's too slow.
No!
Oh no, no, no, no, no!
Oh my gosh.
You!
They're all coming back.
They're all coming...
Oh my gosh.
No!
No, please!
Please just leave.
Oh my gosh.
I don't think he's going to leave in time.
They're too slow!
Oh no, no, no, no, no!
Wait!
Please leave.
Oh my god.
Existence is pain.
Oh my gosh.
Please!
Hot frog!
We made it!
Oh my gosh.
Oh...
Sweet.
Release.
Oh...
Oh my gosh.
Hip, hip, zumbini!
I don't even...
What other path can I take?
Which seat can I take?
I think I screwed everything up.
By using the magic wand too much.
I played God and I'm...
I played God and I...
I'm regretting it.
I shouldn't have done it.
Oh my gosh.
Aqua blue?
Oh, you're right.
Did I make that one?
Or...
Being God is suffering.
I wonder how many crabs are here.
I wonder how many crabs we can accumulate before we crash the game.
Do they just end up despawning or...
How many crabs can we grab?
Hmm...
I want to take that path.
But I can't.
Oh my gosh.
They just keep coming.
You can tell there's new ones because they're...
These guys just given up.
They don't even move.
They don't care anymore.
There's only one way to know.
What else can we...
What else do we have here?
Uh... X?
Oh, flower?
Flower?
The flower could maybe work.
I gotta use my...
I gotta play God again.
Wait,
where did it start?
Where did I start the flower at?
Did I just mess up?
Am I an idiot?
I think I'm dumb, you guys.
I think I'm stupid.
We regained.
We...
It's fine.
And flower.
Is this modded?
Modded Zoombinis.
Only for the hardcore Zoombinis fans.
Yeah.
You know.
Wait, what is that guy doing?
What are you doing?
Oh my gosh, I think there's...
I think they've...
Oh, nope, never mind.
They're still coming.
Mod Zoombinis into wisps?
Oh my gosh, that'd be crazy.
What one was it?
The flower?
There we go.
Here we go.
Oh no.
Wait, there might be a clash.
Oh, okay.
It's fine.
He'll make it back.
I think...
I don't think I like this mini-game anymore.
Okay, let's go to another one, because this one...
The crabs are too much for me.
No, don't do it.
That's what I thought.
Back off.
Silence.
Finally.
No more brain-scritching sounds.
I'm just so curious what some of these other puzzles would be like super hard.
You know what I mean?
Like, what's this one?
Well,
what do we have here?
Okay, so, wait, so... I don't really care.
So, like, they would have to have something...
And then they would...
Oh my... I don't think it's cross.
I don't think it's cross.
Luckily.
But like that... oh wait!
No, she doesn't have a red nose.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this one works though.
This one works.
Does this one... does this one go for the... wait.
I guess just this.
I'm going by nose color currently.
I wasn't in the beginning, but now I am.
Nose.
That's our only pink.
There you go, you got it.
What nose?
What are you talking about?
They all have noses.
Don't give me your sass.
Nose!
Oh, okay.
I was going to say, is he gone?
Hey Mint, out of curiosity, did you ever play a game called Virtual Villagers?
I remember playing this game and Virtual Villagers a lot as a kid.
I never played a Virtual Villagers.
No.
I had not played that.
Sure!
I think I screwed up with her.
See, but this one won't work.
Crab's alive!
Crab's alive?
What does that mean?
Crab's alive!
Oh my gosh, this one's hard.
This one's hard.
Don't like how the fish looks?
Oh, I just noticed them.
Eww.
Hmm.
Minecraft villager.
Crab died.
Hmm.
Trying to figure out what would be the easiest thing to focus on, you know?
Okay, redo, redo, redo, redo.
Redo, redo, redo.
He's floating.
These poor guys don't even have names.
That's so sad.
Practice Zumbini one.
Okay, practice Zumbini.
Fine, sit wherever you want to.
I don't really care.
Starting from the center.
Hmm.
So if I'm like...
Okay, let's just place these guys kind of randomly.
Oh.
She worked, but...
You.
Sure!
And you.
Are four.
And they each have different eyes!
Wait, this kind of works.
This kind of works, maybe.
Maybe.
Okay.
Is this...
No.
Wait.
No, does...
Which one does this go with?
How...
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see, I see.
Ah, sure.
Yeah.
Um...
Hmm.
The nose color always throws me off.
Because it's like the last thing I look at.
Um...
Red nose...
Rudolph...
The red nose reindeer.
You have nothing in common.
Hmm.
Oh, no.
No!
I
should have delayed it.
Thank you!
Phew!
Praise the sun.
These animations are nuts, I know.
The one thing that really is so impressive to me, looking at stuff like Freddy Fish, is just how much the game is all animated.
I'm going to be out here.
Hey, calm down mister.
I'm thinking, okay?
My brain runs a little more slowly.
I wonder instead in the center, maybe I should do the nose colors.
Because I feel like that might be the...
Where'd he go?
Uh oh.
Like if it's...
Wait.
Like red?
No, but they have nothing in common.
They have nothing in common.
Oh.
I was like, oh no.
I think I just sacrificed her.
Phew.
To the crabs you go.
Crabs alive!
The crabs are alive with the taste of blood.
I never understood what this wanted us to do.
You have to...
So, the person next to them has to have one matching feature.
Sorry.
Zumbini.
Next to them has to have one matching feature.
So, in this case, it would be like either the hair or the nose color or the feet or the eyes.
Well, that's the only thing that can match.
All aboard.
I'm getting board.
Shut up.
What?
Back on shore then, Bubba.
Wait.
No.
I'm so confused.
They have the same feet.
What?
But they have the same feet.
Diagonal counts?
No.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm going to test this.
It does count.
No way.
Diagonal does count.
That's so evil.
What?
I think the board is f'ed.
It's supposed to be a 4x4 board, but it's all stacked.
That's what's confusing me about it.
So, that's why I was just like...
Okay.
I was counting them because I was just like...
So, even though it kind of looks like it would go to this one, it goes to this one because it's the third one.
But it's not.
It's very confusing.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
So, because like this one...
Does it go to all three?
It must.
And then this one goes to two.
This one goes to three.
Okay.
So, it's three or two.
I can't tell.
It's like a hex board.
A hex board.
Yeah, this is very, very hard.
Wow.
Wait.
So, if it's just hard, is it like a regular grid?
It's very, very hard.
This is for children?
This is for...
There you go.
You got it.
This is for babies?
Are you sure?
Oh my gosh.
Green nose.
Oh.
He didn't match with this guy.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
This feels impossible.
Is there...
Is there actually...
There's only one.
There's only one way you could do this.
Might have to abandon some guy's hair.
Alternative title, only for baby geniuses.
So, they must have at least one matching feature with adjacent ones.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's...
That's the thing.
Only one per seat.
Oh, sorry.
There you go.
You got it.
Sorry.
Oh no.
Because I...
At least he came back.
Thank you.
Thanks for your generosity.
Sure.
So like, her.
And then...
What even would match here?
Oh, maybe like a...
Cyclops...
No.
It's like, I need a Cyclops.
A Cyclops.
With a spring... with this hair.
It's so difficult.
This is too complicated.
Next puzzle.
This one I feel like would be impossible.
Like actually.
Wait,
it's the exact same.
Hard Crystal is fun, is it?
That's the one where you get to mix and match the Zumbinis, right?
Mint realizes she can't do any very hard puzzle.
Hey, hey, hey!
I'm taste testing.
I'm seeing why each one is very, very hard, okay?
This one feels the exact same though.
Am I...
This one feels the exact same.
So we need a roller skater.
You.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's the...
I...
Wait.
Hmm.
The nose.
Wait, but the nose...
Does the nose correspond with the skates or the eyes?
Does the nose color correspond...?
Oh, jeez...
Okay, hold on this one.
Okay, the hair is completely different.
It's all mixed up.
It's all...
Everything is wrong.
Everything is wrong!
Okay, so the eyes are the hair.
So we need a scruffly hair with the booties.
The booties are green.
I'm gonna guess this because I'm trying to get this guy.
It's either this guy or this guy.
Let's guess
this guy.
Scruffed hair, nose green.
Yeah.
But both of them have green noses.
Let's do this one.
Wait.
No, this one.
Yeah!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
So the first one... So it's green nose corresponds to the feet.
Okay.
So we need a green nose and we need a yellow nose.
Right?
Green nose and yellow nose.
So I'm gonna separate.
You go over... You... Everybody else go over here.
Green nose, yellow nose.
And not scruffly hair.
Oh wait.
Yes?
Wait.
I'm forgetting words.
What?
Corresponded to what part?
Wait.
The hair corresponded to the eyes.
The hair's corresponded to the eyes.
So no scruffly hair.
We need dotted eyes.
We need you.
Just kidding.
Oh, dang it.
I got the hair.
Never mind.
Wait.
No scruffly hair is what I said.
Oh, it was this hair.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so silly.
I got it wrong.
It's him though.
It's him.
What?
We're gonna lose a few zumbinis.
Wait.
Is it not the... Okay.
Huh?
Hm?
The green corresponds to the feet.
So it's her then?
Cause we...
Wait.
What does the eyes correspond to then?
The hair.
Eyes correspond to the hair.
I can't keep track of this.
I need this written down.
I can't keep track of it in my brain.
I'm a visual person.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Goodbye scruffled... scruffled hair, yellow nose.
Scruffled hair, yellow nose.
Oh.
He just walks off.
See ya.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Alrighty, alrighty, alrighty, alrighty, alrighty, alrighty, alrighty.
The feet correspond with the nose color.
So... what?
We have all yellow.
Two.
Thank you.
And we need... the eye color... or the eye corresponds to the...
To the hair.
It's her.
Wait.
No.
Hold on.
Wait.
I'm so confused.
I really need this written out for real.
I need this written out for real.
What went to the... Wait.
What changes the hair again?
What changes... Yeah.
Take notes.
I need to.
My brain can't.
Oh my gosh.
Zumbini hair equals... eyes.
Okay.
So... Okay.
It's one of these guys.
Okay.
It's not her.
It's one of these guys.
Okay.
It's not her.
It's one of these guys.
Feet... become...
Do we have any roller blade guys?
We don't.
Feet become...
Feet.
No.
Wait.
So...
Let's see.
What is it?
Feet change the nose color?
Is that what it is?
No.
Eyes change the nose color.
It must be.
Right?
Because...
They have the same.
But they... Oh.
They also have the same nose.
But also.
I think.
And then...
What else can we change?
Oh.
The legs.
Legs determine...
Some...
I really need this right now.
I think it's the left boy.
Hold on.
I need to figure out why though.
What else is...
Wait.
What does... What changes the...
Hold on.
I'm writing this in a notepad.
Okay.
Hair equals feet.
For the Zoombinis.
Uh...
Eyes equals nose color.
Zoombini eyes equals nose color.
Then...
What changes the...
So it would be...
What do all three... Do these three have in common?
What
do they have in common to...
Get this hair color?
The nose is the feet?
Oh.
You're right.
Nose...
Wait.
Huh?
It's not the hair equals...
Wait.
Oh.
Nose...
Okay.
Sorry.
Zoombini nose equals feet.
You're right.
Yes.
Zoombini nose equals feet.
So what does that leave?
I have...
Oh.
I need...
Zoombini feet equals...
What do I not have?
So the feet equals the hair?
But that doesn't make any sense.
Because these three have the same hair.
These guys have nothing in common.
Seems like feet don't mean anything.
Thank you!
You seem...
You strike me as the kind of ghost who...
grew up with brain quest.
Confirm deny.
I don't know what brain quest is.
So...
I guess I must deny.
Fleeing hair is currently unbound.
Oh my gosh.
So it's random?
So it's either...
It's one of these guys?
Oh no.
It's just one of them?
We don't know?
I don't feel like...
No way there's no logic to it.
Right?
Like...
But...
But seriously...
Like how could...
This hair...
And these three guys...
You know?
Like...
That doesn't make any sense.
Okay guys.
Let's make a poll.
Which...
Which Zoombini?
Left?
Right?
Okay.
Which Zoombini?
On the left!
We have...
Rollerblade Madness!
He is insane.
He will do wheelies for hours.
He is always grinding.
Every moment he gets.
Rollerblade Madness.
On the left...
I mean...
Sorry.
On the right...
We have Walk.
This guy can walk.
He is just...
Even the poll isn't sure.
Then it's not just me.
Oh man.
Wait so...
Right's feet corresponds to fleeing cowboy boots.
No, no, no.
Nelson?
You are living in the past.
This is the present.
We are on very, very hard.
Where all logic has been thrown out the window.
It is different here.
Watch it not be either of these two.
Alright.
59% said left.
So let's go with left.
Okay.
It's all the features.
But the hair.
No way.
It's actually random.
Because look, this one...
Goes to...
No.
They have nothing in common!
Sheesh!
That one was crazy.
Someone said the crystal one is...
Wait, did they say the crystal one was fun?
Oh yeah, yeah, with the...
Oh!
Wait...
Bing!
So we have to make...
Huh?
Oh!
Wait...
Huh?
Oh!
Do I have to wait for it to come back?
No!
That's not what I picked!
Can you put one on the left as well?
Oh, you can!
You can!
You can.
But I'm so concerned about it looking like it's yellow.
Oh wait.
Oh, this is a combo.
Wait.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on.
I don't know if it matters, but...
Now it's saying it's pink?
Why is it changing colors?
Why can't you just be yellow?
This is so confusing.
What?
The nose changes colors when you move spaces.
Yeah, it was...
Yellow on this side.
So I think I have to get the right...
Com...
Oh, see, see, see!
This is the right combination.
But there's no other...
Unless...
It's...
No...
I gotta get the...
The wombo combo.
No?
Never mind.
But there's no other way to change the nose color.
I had it?
Oh, it's yellow!
Sorry.
Yes.
It's yellow.
You're right.
Sorry.
For some reason, I was thinking a different color.
Okay.
You're so right.
So that...
Should...
Do...
It!
What the?
Who are you?
What?
A stranger appeared, you guys.
I don't understand it at all.
I don't understand it at all!
How am I supposed to do two hairstyles at once?
Try the question mark.
Making mistakes is life or death, narrator!
If a few of our little blue friends are left behind, they'll be waiting at shade tree to try again.
Becoming protection.
Okay.
This doesn't make me feel any better.
These ones don't change.
There's...
There's... I need yellow.
Right?
For her.
What is going on?
What is happening?
How am I supposed to get this haircut?
It makes no sense.
No wonder I couldn't beat this.
It doesn't make any sense.
Am I... Am I...
Am I the...
No, I need a degree for this game.
Glasses plus nose and spring on left.
But why?
Also, does it matter?
The... Because it's red.
It's gonna make it red.
Two.
Thank you.
I don't think I need the glasses.
Here, right?
I just need this?
Wait.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
Hold on.
So, I need them to both have this hairstyle.
First of all.
Because they're both gonna match the hair.
Okay.
We don't need the nose.
Because... And we need the spring.
So, she's going to become...
Like this.
Okay.
Oh, but we need the...
Actually, we do need the nose.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
We do need the nose for her.
Can I do three?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
This should be it.
Does it need to be in order or...
It doesn't need to be in order, clearly.
We cooked.
Yeah.
That one was...
This is crazy.
I get it now, though.
I get it.
So, it...
Okay.
Interesting.
God gamer.
This one's fine.
Okay.
This one's actually pretty interesting.
Well, I'll just have the same hair.
Okay.
Sounds good to me.
Now, if I just match these...
No.
Skates.
Hmm.
Big brain.
Probably matters the order of the mirrors.
It didn't seem like it before.
Okay.
So, I'm not quite sure.
Wait.
So, I have a question.
I wonder...
I wonder if it, like, starts...
Wait.
Does it cycle through these?
Like, even when we're going through?
It wouldn't do that to us, right?
We do definitely have to change the eyes.
Like, so...
For example, I do this.
No, that makes no sense.
Why are these ones flashing?
It makes me nervous.
Oh, because I can change it to something else.
Oh.
Front will replace the back?
It will?
Are we sure about that?
Wait.
Okay.
So...
Hold on.
I'm just gonna place some things on the side.
I'm just gonna place...
So, if I have it...
Hair?
Wait.
All we need for this one...
Okay.
If it's this...
First?
Huh?
Oh, well, this one's also...
Never mind.
This one also is gonna get the hair.
Still need the eyes on the left.
Yeah.
You're right.
Boom.
This one turns into a plane.
This one...
Oh.
Ah.
Oh-oh.
I think I'm breaking the game.
Is this the one I...
Wait.
This one.
Take out.
My Oshi with the 998 IQ.
Think of it like Photoshop layers.
Okay.
I think...
Oh, I...
Okay.
I get it.
I think.
I think...
But we need the eyes... here.
Okay.
But...
Well we only... need... okay.
Essentially what I'm like... struggling with is...
Is this guy and this guy... they have mostly matching features.
We need the nose though.
Ah...
Layer closest to the middle is the top layer.
Yeah...
But I think what I'm confused about is how it will work the second round.
You know what I mean?
Like...
So... the spark will hap...
So... the first... so I... this...
Wait, will this last?
All...
Yeah,
the blocks won't change, only the turntable and the zoomines.
Exactly.
So I need them to...
It feels like I need them to match on both sides.
Like... or have the same exact things.
But the... when I put the plates... when I put these crystals down, they don't.
See?
We get a little propeller man.
Get this...
Don't worry about the flashing.
Are you sure?
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, wait, I think I get it.
Okay, so because this is in front...
It won't recognize the wheel.
Right?
Is that what you...
Okay.
So... it'll be like...
Okay, the hair is on, the nose and this is on, and then the eyes are on.
So then...
You guys, the game is breaking.
Oh no, he's stuck!
Oh, okay, we're good.
Okay.
No!
Uh oh.
You guys, I think I broke the game.
I think I broke the game.
Oh no!
Oh, we were so close right when I got it!
Right when I understood!
We...
I...
No!
Right when I understood!
Oh!
Okay, I'm gonna try anyway.
It made a noise.
Who was that?
Wait, what?
Why is...
It changed the hair to the girl's hair!
Why?
What?
I think the game broke a little.
It was this hair before!
Okay, okay, let's redo, redo, redo, redo.
Redo, redo, redo, redo.
Okay.
No, the nose is fine.
Um.
We'll just do... does it matter if I... what legs I do?
I guess?
I guess it wants me to do these.
Because it gave me two of them.
Okay, does this look correct?
It gives us the eyes, the...
Thank you.
That looks correct?
Yeah!
Yippee!
Wait, why does it have a pink nose?
Where'd the green nose go?
You know what?
It's fine.
They made it through.
Okay!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Let's see.
Let's see what the...
other hair is.
Okay, okay.
What's the glasses on the side?
Sad.
What was it on the side?
Glasses.
Sad.
How logical are these Zoombinis, chat?
There is something going on here.
I'm not gonna play for too much longer.
Um, actually, you know what?
Because I do want to see a few of the other things...
on the super hard, let's go back.
Um... Sorry, I meant very, very hard.
We're, like, at the hardest.
Like the... this one.
It's the exact same.
Maybe it's, like, tinier traits that he likes and dislikes.
Okay, never mind.
Yes, but trickier.
I think these ones are typically gonna be the same.
This one I know has a lot more rooms.
What?!
Hello!
Guess what?
We're going on tour!
But thanks to you and your cousins, this place has grown!
You are too much!
Mwah!
Can't drop down right now.
But have fun!
It's better than having none!
I didn't expect this many rooms!
Oh my god!
What?!
I've never seen this many rooms before.
What if I just stick you here?
Okay...
But they all... they went into the...
This one is in half, though.
Why are there so many rooms?
What?
Huh?
Thank you!
Did you see the first episode of the Blue Archive anime?
Yes!
I watched it!
I actually watched it earlier.
I watched it before stream.
Oh my gosh!
They're so cute!
The opening is so cute!
It's five by five by five.
Yeah, but...
Wait, is it already starting to get darker?
Is the time limit so much...
Like, it's so funny because...
You can see...
Where it's like...
The line of darkness.
But they're also not showing you the clock.
But yeah...
The Blue Archive anime is so cute!
The opening is so cute!
Oh, they're so cute!
It's super duper cute.
I'm just gonna put...
At random.
This is so...
Bizarre.
Oh!
I did it!
It's not by nose color.
Unless it's by nose color and...
Something else.
Already?!
Ma'am, I haven't even...
I'm closing the hotel for the night.
So scamper into a room.
Things have changed as the path has become more difficult.
But the Zubinis have faith in you, brave explorer!
You have all the information you need to complete this challenge!
And get your Zubinis through!
I do?
I have all the information?
Do I actually?
Ow!
What about like you?
Okay.
Next one.
Let's see.
Oh, this one probably would be...
Wait, what is this?
Oh, the color of the star too?
Oh!
Wait, lucky us!
Wait.
No, no, no.
Oh my gosh.
Let's just try pink.
This one's insane!
Thanks for showing us your childhood game, Blue Archive Love!
Yes!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, it was so cute!
It was really fun seeing some of the other characters.
Like the delinquent girls and things like that.
Them kind of in motion.
And everything.
It was fun.
It was really cute.
So what?
What is...
Okay.
The green...
So it has to be...
Okay.
Wait.
It's gotta be green.
Because I think it corresponds to this grid.
Right?
The five by five.
And so...
It's the first one.
So it's gonna be star...
Maybe.
Let's try pink.
No, not pink.
Yellow.
Red.
No.
Blue.
Oh, wait.
Green.
I did the wrong one.
Green here.
I'm silly.
Wait then.
What's on the third row?
Wait.
But I was right about the first column being the green.
It's just...
The classic splat dot wave.
So it's correct about the green being here.
And the blue is here.
What determines it down here though?
Is the question.
Is the big Q.
Try a different shape.
But then why would this shape go there?
Wait.
Are the shapes all wacky?
Wackadoodle too?
I think they're different for each one.
Oh my gosh.
We did it.
Nice.
I think they're different for each one.
Because if I did like a square here.
Would it go up there?
Let's test it out.
This is our...
No.
I can't be wasting ink.
So this is a triangle down here.
This too.
Oh.
Not...
I was like don't go wasting ink.
Huh?
What?
Oh yeah.
I completed it.
Yeah.
And I'm doing hard work.
I'm just testing out what the...
I think the shapes can't be in the same column.
Like what is the pattern here?
There's obviously the color which we got.
Are they di...
No.
They're not diagonal.
It feels so random.
So the one next to it can't be touching the same shape?
Is that what you guys are saying?
Like a sudoku?
Kind of?
Ink don't...
What?
We ran out of ink so fast.
They don't even let you experiment a little.
No way.
Okay.
So pink.
Let's try and get this next three.
But how will I...
I figured this game would only have like 10 games total.
I'm shocked that you're still playing it.
I'm going through stuff.
I'm going through it.
You have all the info you need.
Okay.
So maybe it's not a circle then.
Thank
you so much.
Thank you.
And...
Oh.
So it's gonna be...
Red is the only one.
So close.
Oh my gosh.
Square?
Why would it be square?
You were right though.
But why?
The shape is two to the right and one up.
Huh?
I think we're out of ink.
Oh we get one more shot.
We could save two more maybe.
Let's do the green because we know this one.
And it's uh...
Red inside.
Ink is loading.
Hold on.
Isn't there a thing for this?
One second.
I think there's a...
Uh...
Wait.
Yeah I got it.
This.
It's triangle.
Green...
Yeah it's always gonna be...
Green sphere, red triangle.
Why is it triangle though?
How are you guys so good at this?
For this one?
We saved the final two.
No more ink left.
Yes.
Zoombinis were left behind.
But the knowledge was gained.
Press on.
Brave explorer.
Oh no.
Yes.
Zoombinis were left behind.
Oh my gosh.
They encourage you to leave them.
What about this one?
Okay anyway.
This one actually looks kind of fun.
I'm not gonna lie.
There's also...
I remember there being another one up here.
What is this?
What does this do?
What are these?
Wait.
Galaxy hole.
The music is like...
Making more music.
The music was not like this before.
Was it?
This is new music.
I don't think I've ever heard this before.
Also how...
Are you supposed to just go across?
Is that even possible?
I'm gonna send...
No.
I'm not gonna send someone to their doom.
Wait.
Can I get you over there?
Oh!
How do I get you over there?
Did it play Robocop for a moment?
What's this thing on the left?
This is the thing that creates the bubbles.
What is the yellow...
Okay.
I'm gonna test this.
Cause I wanna know...
What the yellow and the...
What all this does.
I wanna know what the green does.
I wanna know what the yellow does.
Oh wait.
Maybe it...
Aha!
It does.
Okay.
What's this?
What does the green do?
Huh?
Are you stuck?
Uh oh.
I think my Zoombini is trapped.
If I push her...
Oh!
Maybe I can like...
Push her over.
Maybe?
Let's send...
I feel like some of these...
I have to... when I do them...
It sends them to their doom.
Send another one?
Oh wait.
I think I just...
Uh oh.
Goodbye!
Sayounara!
Let's try... this way.
Look.
Now we're safe.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Push.
Push her.
Zoombinis.
Oh!
You murdered her!
You murderer!
You!
You killed her!
I cannot believe...
The...
This is...
I'm disgusted.
I'm disgusted in this display right now.
I can't even... I can't even...
I can't... I cannot even deal with these Zoombinis any longer.
Hold on.
I wanna see this one.
Huh?
It doesn't tell you.
It just says...
You figure it out.
That's very hard mode.
It just doesn't tell you.
That is so funny.
Thank you!
Where do the Zoombinis go when they get accidentally...
They go back to camp.
It's fine.
They're fine.
I like the music in that one.
What one haven't we seen?
This one?
I think it's probably the same as...
Like the...
The bridge.
I think we've seen everything else.
Very cool.
They go to the shadow realm.
Crystal?
We did the crystal one too.
Yeah.
That was fun.
What a blast from the past.
Hold on.
Bing bing bing.
Bing bing bing bing.
I am going to...
Go here.
Hello.
I am too slow.
Ouch!
Stop it!
Let me close out of Zoombinis real quick.
Let me put on some BGM.
And...
Give me a second.
BGM.
Hold on.
I have to make sure it's...
There we go.
Thank you guys.
For...
Whatever that brain...
Battle.
Battle of the wits.
Open here.
That was so fun.
Oh my gosh.
That was so much fun.
It was awesome.
Revisiting that.
For sure.
My brain hurts.
From some of those.
I didn't expect the very very hard...
To be as difficult as it was.
I surpassed my expectations.
Entirely.
Good job showing off your mighty brain cell.
Thank you.
I know.
You might be intimidated.
By how...
Well.
I was able to perceive things.
But you too.
Can...
Can become my level.
At some point.
Thanks for streaming.
Mint.
Thank you.
Thanks for the stream.
I will be reading donations out.
So if you're gonna head out.
See you later.
Tomorrow I have off.
Because the podcast.
Will be released.
So.
Yeah.
And...
Podcast Mondays.
Yippee.
Umm...
Yeah.
That really made me want pizza.
More than anything.
Thank you.
I'm buying this game now.
Completely missed it way back when.
Thanks for the stream, Minty.
Of course.
There's gonna be an uptick in Zumbini sales.
Maybe.
It is very fun though.
And it's...
I didn't realize.
I never noticed.
That on the map.
It showed like how many Zumbinis were left on Zumbini Isle.
Yeah.
Zumbini Island, right?
And then you move them to...
No.
Zumbini Island...
Wait.
Zumbini Isle is the new one, right?
Zumbini Pachinko Machine.
I hope never.
Yeah.
Zumbini Island to Zumbini Ville.
That's right.
Yeah.
So...
What happens when you get all to the island?
I have no idea because...
I think as a kid I never noticed that there was an amount.
But I always just...
Played it.
I don't even know.
I think that's a new addition from the original game.
Who knows.
But as a kid I just never noticed it.
Yeah.
I got to squeeze in a run to this stream.
Thanks.
No problem.
Let's get this off my head.
Good bye.
Here.
Let's put something else on my head.
Um...
This is me.
I'm bread.
Because I'm brain dead.
You're a soup.
Thank you.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Go see my friends.
Who doesn't watch VTubers but love Zumbini's was watching.
And had a blast.
As for those we lost, we won't see them.
And as ashes.
They're all diamonds.
They are diamonds.
Zumbini is so true.
I hope this becomes the next flavor of the month streamer game.
So VTubers everywhere can show the world what they are.
That they are not in fact smarter than a first grader.
Hey!
I proved myself.
I proved myself pretty well I think.
Now that the Microsoft cops can't stop us.
I'm going to be a flight sim.
Oh my gosh.
It's so crazy you bring that up.
Because I was watching something yesterday.
And they brought up flight simulator.
And I was like, I can do that.
So, 12 hour stream baby.
Let's fly to Japan.
We can fly.
I've always wanted to do that.
So...
It's funny.
Maybe I should have done it.
Back when I streamed 3 years ago.
But...
Oh well.
How... I do wonder though.
Like how much do I...
Need to know...
Of flying a plane.
To do it.
I actually have looked into getting a pilot's license before.
But...
Oh my gosh.
A pilot's license is actually insane.
Not that I have a plane to fly anyway.
But...
My...
One of my old bosses...
Had a...
A pilot's license.
And so...
I don't know.
Maybe I should ask him.
Hey, can you teach me how to fly?
It was a semi-popular thing to do in my uni.
What do you go to a uni of...
People like...
Who sleep on gold?
Getting a pilot's license is so expensive.
I just wanna...
You know...
As a ghost, I can fly anyway.
But I just kinda wanna look...
Fly is like a...
I can float.
Big word.
But...
Pilot's license for small planes...
Is easy and not that bad.
Okay, I'm gonna say...
The price that I saw...
And...
Anyone who wants to confirm...
Can confirm.
I saw...
It was for...
10,000 US dollars.
Is that correct?
Oh, I heard about 10k.
See?
That's what I heard.
That's what I googled and it told me.
I googled it.
Yeah, that's about right.
Oh my god.
10k is low?
Oh my god, we got...
Mr. Morbucks over here.
Commercial is like...
150k?
10k is low for a pilot's license though.
Okay.
It's like 7 MGS3 Pachi slot machines.
Sheesh.
Do pilots make good money?
Like, say if I were a pilot for...
Some big company?
Do they make...
The fact that you have to pay 150...
Thousand dollars?
I
mean...
Okay.
When I think about it...
Okay, hold on.
That doesn't include school, right?
Because...
Some...
Some colleges in the United States...
Cost that much...
Intuition and things like that.
So...
It doesn't include school.
It's just like the...
The test.
That's so crazy.
Not that I would get the commercial license anyway.
But...
But actually...
I don't know.
Like, what...
How...
How commercial are we talking?
Because if I...
If I'm just like...
Hey guys, I have a plane...
But I need you to pay...
For my time...
Is that commercial?
I mean...
If I don't have a business...
If I'm just sometimes like...
Oh, and you can tell your friends...
That I have a plane...
But I'm gonna charge them a little bit more...
Because they're not my friends.
You know?
Getting the 747...
You guys, I'm gonna fly a Boeing.
Pfft...
Okay.
Next stream idea.
Pfft...
If I'm going down...
I'm taking you all with me.
Pfft...
Boeing hand cam.
I'm not ready to die yet.
It's okay.
You're wisps.
Pfft...
Pspsps...
Oh...
It's so scary that I have to check every time now.
When I'm like getting a flight...
I'm just like...
This is...
I don't wanna have anxiety the entire flight.
You know what I mean?
Worth it.
Crash landing on a desert...
Deserted island stream.
Rest in pieces.
Pfft...
Oh...
Sorry, Mint.
I want my pilot to be able to recognize their subvenius names.
I don't think I could even become a pilot anyway because...
You have to have like good vision, right?
Unfortunately, I wear contacts.
Even as a ghost.
You're thinking...
Even in death, my vision would be better.
Oh, it's a myth.
Did you guys know that...
Actually...
I don't know if this is only Delta.
I saw videos on it.
But I think everyone that I saw with the videos did Delta.
But um...
Some pilots have trading cards.
Of their...
Of the plane.
So if you're just like...
Hi, can I talk to the pilot?
And you can collect cards of the planes.
Isn't that so awesome?
I wanted to do it last time but I was really...
I was like...
What if they were like...
What the hell are you talking about?
I was nervous to ask.
Wait, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look it up.
It's so cool.
I don't know if it's just Delta though.
But um...
Every time I've watched a video about it...
The pilots are so nice.
But I think because it went viral on TikTok...
A lot of people have been asking and so the pilots will be like...
The pilots will be like...
Oh, I'm out.
People keep asking for these all of the sudden.
Sorry, Minto.
If I hear this is your captain speaking and it's your voice...
I'm jumping out right there and then...
This is your captain speaking.
The local temperature is...
You need a sweater, but a really light sweater.
You know?
And we're coming in at an altitude of craziness.
Buckle up, baby!
Wooooo!
Have you seen that furry who's a technician?
And writes oh whoa on the fuel tank?
I have seen that.
I have seen it.
It's so crazy.
So funny.
Buckle up, whisperers.
We're going shopping.
What happens if you LASIK a ghost?
I will never get LASIK.
So, I don't know.
Do they just go straight through?
There's so many mysteries about ghosts.
So many.
Oh, I just went to...
That's funny.
I went to YouTube.
Because I was like, time to read Super Chats.
I don't have Super Chats.
Can I...
I don't even...
Yeah, I'll show...
I'm almost halfway to the amount of hours that I need...
to get...
monetization.
So, we'll see.
I don't know.
I'm not gonna worry about it, though.
I'm not too concerned, to be honest.
Force of habit.
Are they gonna...
I'll get LASIK if they...
What's the word?
They put Sharingan in my eyes.
How long do you have to be inactive for where it resets?
I don't know.
It was a long time.
I can't remember, though.
Maybe several months.
Three months or something.
I don't know.
I don't think I have the emails anymore.
Where it's just like, Hey, you're gonna not have membership...
You're gonna not have monetization anymore.
Oh, I don't have a thing that says Dono reading.
Hold on.
Um...
Text.
Donation reading time.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I need a font.
Uh...
Oh...
Beep.
I don't know.
Let's outline it.
Outline it in...
Mint.
Mint...
Like...
A little more...
Like that.
Cool.
Yippee!
Mint, mint, mint.
Stimp.
You might not become a pilot, but now that you're out of heaven, you could get that forklift certification.
I could!
I could get forklift certified if I wanted to.
Perhaps I should?
Mint phantom.
Certified forklifter.
Let's put it...
Right!
Why is it so...
Why is it like that?
Why is it spaced like that?
Also, I don't think I like the...
Everything being capitalized.
That's...
Better.
Am I box certified?
Look into the game.
DCS.
You get to fly fighter jets.
The game is very, very hard.
You need a HOTAS.
But you want to try...
Wait...
But you want to try to fly a game that is a step above Microsoft Flight.
You can fly like Maverick and do air support for Snake.
F-15 Super Hornet is a plane...
One...
One step at a time, maybe.
My new job has me driving a forklift and I can confirm that they're simultaneously very fun and very frustrating.
It's not like a...
What's the word?
It's not stick shift or...
But there's like a lever you have to pull and stuff.
Isn't there?
Am I going crazy?
DCS is not a game.
It's a job.
But yeah...
I'm going to read Streamlabs now.
Actually, I don't...
Streamlabs has changed so much.
I can't...
Okay, I think if I go to here I'll be able to read it.
Yes.
Wait, why is it showing me 11 minutes ago and then 3 years ago?
Stop it.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks for bringing back the good morning tweets.
Well, in the past I used to say Oha Minto.
Um... but...
Um...
I don't know.
I can say Oha Minto or Good Morning Minto or whatever.
3 years ago.
I think this is... No.
Wait, hold on.
This doesn't work either.
No!
Streamlabs, why do you have to change everything?
I can't... Wait, this... Okay.
Oh!
I have to go here.
Streamlabs history.
I figured it out.
What's today?
7th.
7!
George Costanza.
I think I just messed something up.
One.
One full BS.
I messed something up too.
Stop!
OBS, why did you...
Everything is bad.
Offering to my local ghost.
Thank you!
I just got here.
Why are you bread?
Because my brain is dead.
My brain is dead from Zoombini time.
dead from Zoombini time.
My brain is dead.
The hard was actually difficult.
I'm so shocked.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm getting hungry for dinner so...
I'm gonna read through these and then I'll see you guys on Tuesday.
Oh my no.
It's a horror game though.
Oh no, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
A soup.
Here's a streamlabs from zero minutes ago.
Thanks.
Can I have a piece of that bread?
You're wanting my...
My brain?
You want a piece of my brain?
Bread equals brain is dead?
Yeah.
Bread.
Brain dead.
If we're airing our flight sim, Rainworms, I think that IL2 Stermovic is a better game for learning the basics of combat flight than DCS.
Flying World War 2 prop planes teaches you better fundamentals.
Oh my god.
Start at the basics.
Okay, where's my Wright Brothers sim then, guys?
If I'm starting at the basics, I'm starting at the basics.
We need the Wright Brothers here.
Then I'll move on from that to basic.
Never.
Build it yourself.
Icarus sim?
We're going way back then.
Oh, true.
We gotta go even further beyond.
Offering to our local Ryan Gosling.
He's not here.
Is he?
Mr. Ryan?
I missed Mint Phantom so much.
Mint cheer, mint cheer, mint cheer.
Thanks for having me.
Hopefully we'll have emotes again soon.
When I get emotes, when I do, when I get uh...
emotes back, we'll do karaoke.
Hopefully my flight...
My flight?
Dang it.
No, my voice.
Sorry.
It's because I read flight in the chat.
Hopefully my voice will be better by then.
I'm too influenced.
This is why I struggle so much with like um...
You know like how some people can sing harmonies immediately?
Like the people will be like...
I...
I can sing along with the music but instead of singing the song, I'm doing the harmonies.
I... I struggle so much.
I like mimic what I hear.
I mimic what I read.
It's so difficult.
Yeah.
They have the ear for it.
How do they...
Maybe if I plug my ears and do it along.
Maybe it's better.
Maybe.
The New York Times published an opinion.
An article that mankind was millions of years from inventing powered flight nine days before the Wright Brothers' first flight.
Those silly New York Times.
They don't know anything.
They're the non-believers.
The Wright Brothers, they were right.
Goodnight from me.
Goodnight.
Goodnight, goodnight.
Repeating things you hear is called Eccol...
Eccololia.
Actually...
There's a game called Rise of Flight that has World War I and earlier planes and there's an expansion for IL-2 that has them added in.
Flight sim people are crazy.
I love that though.
Love the passion.
Okay.
Um...
Some of these are from before stream and I will still read them.
So I'll just read the stream labs from today.
Uh...
Thank you!
Um...
Sometimes I get...
What's the word?
I get nervous seeing like offline donations.
I do appreciate them very much.
But I get nervous because sometimes it's like a hate message.
So...
I'm just...
If I have my OBS open and I hear that I get a donation, I'm like...
But I understand if you can't make it to the stream or something.
So I do still appreciate it.
You know?
So, thank you.
Um...
Anonymous, thank you!
Uh...
That's a nice message.
I really appreciate it.
That's a...
Dado, thank you!
I played this so much as a kid.
Love the logic puzzles.
I even bought them remake.
You're playing for my niece!
Everyone deserves zumbinis in their childhood.
It's just such a good puzzle game.
It's so fun.
Try to ignore the anti ones.
Yeah, I do.
I do, I do.
I mostly usually ignore them.
So...
Thanks for the money, nerd.
For bullying them.
I feel like...
Give me your money, punk!
Taking your lunch money.
Um...
Thank you!
And Ronan, thank you again!
Um...
Hope you're having a wonderful day!
You too!
Tyranzor Catastrophe, thank you!
Murphy, thank you!
Good luck with your job tomorrow!
Oh my gosh.
Sub-Zero Mudkips, thank you!
Do you think we'll eventually get a dono rap?
What's that?
Where I rap the donations?
Whoa!
Yo!
Wow this duck!
Thanks very much!
Joan, thank you!
See...
It's good seeing you again!
Ronan, thanks for the donation!
Mr. Yoda, ooh ooh yeah!
Um...
But I can't rap.
I can't dono rap and read the...
Read the messages at the same time.
Um...
Can't believe my Oshii is bullying me for lunch money!
Wapsha!
Yeah.
Good enough for me.
Need a BGM for the beat.
Yeah, for real.
Arigato, arigato!
This game is etching to my soul from 25 plus years ago.
Always great to see someone else who can sing along with the soundtrack.
I'm telling ya.
I played this game way so much.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Um...
Wait...
Oh, yes, there we go.
Karma, thank you!
Mr. Comb Jelly, thank you!
Mr. Yoda, thank you!
Why do so many of the Zoominie names sound like setups for D's nuts jokes?
Azumaya Aru!!
Thank you!
Arigato, arigato!
Good luck guiding the Zoom...
Zooms to salvation!
Customer Johnson, thank you!
Ronin, thank you!
K-Barn, thank you!
Fleece!
Jeremy Abel, thank you!
Albin, thank you!
Cody, thank you!
Kazuko, thank you!
Kazuko!
Oh my gosh!
He's anybody!
Thank you!
So many names I haven't seen in so long.
Nan, thank you!
Sunchips, thank you!
Meep, meep, meep, meep!
Just Scam, thank you!
Ryland, thank you!
Bestest maid ever?
Nah...
Not the bestest maid ever...
No...
Nah...
Stop...
No...
Mmm...
Arigato, arigato!
No...
Zalpios, thank you!
Uh...
Jeffycake, thank you!
KazooMan, thank you!
Is this Scribblenaut?
But maybe...
The predecessor...
Soryoneko, thank you!
I'm fairly new to your stream, but for the short time I've been here, I'm really enjoying what I see.
You mint are such a delight.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Love being minty fresh.
Umeaino, thank you!
JoshuaHugo, thank you!
I've listened to you sing Snake Eater in Heaven's Divide so many times from your return stream, and I'm always in awe of the power of your singing voice.
I'm happy you are back and looking forward to more of your goofiness, my kamiushi.
WAAAH!
Oh my gosh, I'm so embarrassed though, because my throat was giving out.
RayMac, thank you!
ZunbiniFrogXcent, there you go, you got it!
There you go, you got it!
Didn't sound like it?
Oh, it definitely was.
It's full of soul.
Why do you spell soul like that?
With a V.
Soul.
Full of soul.
Hey there, pretty lady.
I feel like I'm reading LeetSpeak.
You know how, like, when they change the E's to 3's?
The T's to 7's?
Ugh.
Treebomber, thank you!
Mindmaster, thank you!
Here's a choot for everyone in Mint Chord.
Nan, thank you!
Eating Mike Tyson's butt, thank you!
MintyFreshKyle, thank you!
Eric W, I thank you!
Maybe if you talk to him in a frog voice, he'll understand and listen.
I should've.
I should've!
The legend.
Thank you guys for the donations!
Impload, thank you!
Mr. Yuta, thank you again!
SithSpawn, thank you!
For great old PC games, you should look up Stay Tuned.
If you haven't seen or played it before, it's so silly and fun.
It's a bit hard to play nowadays, as it doesn't have a modern re-release.
But there are ways to do it.
I'll be honest, I did try to find a way to play the original of the Zumbi.
But...
I couldn't get it to work.
And...
With the time I...
Rather...
What's the word?
How much time I had?
Before stream?
I couldn't get it to work.
But that's okay.
I think this one was still good enough.
Yeah.
Thank you!
Staff member has died.
Oh my god.
Invictus, thank you!
Mint the murderer.
I was just trying to show you something cool.
A death.
Pandapalooza, thank you!
The moment you mentioned Zumbinis yesterday, I had a Pixar flashback moment to 3rd grade computer lab.
This and Treasure Mathstorm were my jam.
Yes!
Ah!
Wildest Duck, thank you!
Mint, you killed a Zumbini.
Amazing!
Mission complete!
That right there is why you're the best boss.
Kaito, thank you!
Isabelle, thank you!
Uh...
David Titanium...
PP, thank you!
Mama...
Just killed a man...
If I do karaoke...
Once I get memberships...
...
What kind of karaoke should I do?
What kind of karaoke?
Whatever you want.
So true.
Nacho Libre OST.
Heavy metal.
My throat is just coming back.
Black metal, please.
Do you guys want me to have a throat?
A voice or not?
I'm not asking you guys.
I'm gonna sing whatever I want.
Uh...
Ease Jimmy, thank you!
Now we know why you're not allowed in heaven anymore.
Stop!
William Luong, thank you!
Fukuro, thank you!
Retro Puffy, thank you!
Rico, thank you!
Puff, thank you!
Uh...
Takedo X, thank you!
Extra... oh, X, thank you!
John, thank you!
Anonymous, thank you!
Never even heard of this game and somehow it's still giving me nostalgic vibes.
Right?
I know.
For sure.
Arigato, arigato!
Chuuu!
Steak da ne?
Steak Dane?
Stecky da ne?
Steak Dane.
Okay, I can try that one.
Seven colors of Nico Nico douka.
Oku sen man!
Chuuu!
Um...
Raven's back, thank you!
I've never played this game but I would always watch the trailer.
Ads for it.
And the Clue Finders game mantra.
Did you ever play any of those games?
I don't think so.
I'm gonna look it up right now.
Clue Finders.
Maybe if I see it, I'll remember.
Oh...
I, for some reason, vaguely remember the Pyramid one.
But maybe I didn't have it.
Maybe a friend had it.
I don't think I had this game.
I think a friend had this one.
And I don't think I had it.
I don't know.
Maybe.
The Pyramid one was a nightmare?
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know.
It looks familiar though.
Maybe because it looks kind of like you know how a lot of like animation from that time looked very much like it kind of looks like the magic school bus.
You know what I mean?
No...
Dog Strings, thank you!
Murphy, thank you!
AJ Shell, thank you!
Mr. Yuta, thank you!
Shrookey, thank you!
Jeremy Abel, thank you!
TV Juice Enjoyer, thank you!
Kaito, thank you!
Jubilathan, thank you!
Scrookster, thank you!
Mr. Yuta, thank you again!
Thank you so much for all the donations!
Gotta beat a leg of the journey perfectly perfectly three times to raise its difficulty by one level.
Okay, okay, okay.
But of course you can just try harder difficulties in practice mode too.
Got it!
Okay.
For whenever I come back to zoom my knees.
JamieDX, thank you!
What a stream for my birthday!
Oh my god, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday JamieDX!
Happy birthday!
Thanks for spending your birthday with us!
Hopefully you get some good cake.
Wait, what time does the store close?
Oh!
Oh, I have an hour!
Okay.
I have an hour to go to the store.
I suddenly wanted a very specific cake that is only sold at a certain store.
So I'm gonna go get that.
Um...
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you!
Ume Aino, thank you!
Italian Loves Cake, thank you!
If they want pizza so bad, why don't they make them?
I know!
And the machine is right there!
Rico, thank you!
Kiki Cadaver, thank you!
Um...
I'll check out that Virtual Villagers thing.
I've never heard of it.
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you!
Shin Solar, thank you!
Osos, thank you!
Seymour, thank you!
Dado, thank you!
People on Steam reported this as a bug, but it hasn't been fixed yet.
I see, I see.
Kaito, thank you!
See you later, Mint!
Many thanks!
No, thank you!
Thanks for hanging out!
Really appreciate it.
Thank you.
I didn't think so many people would be here for...
for...
childhood baby game.
Kaito, thank you!
Minty Fresh Kyle, thank you!
Ume, thank you!
Vivico, thank you!
Akabar, thank you!
Virulent, thank you!
Aria, thank you again for the Akadono!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Um...
Nylok, thank you!
Mint stole another soul.
Thanks for Zoominia's fun stream.
Looking forward to podcast Monday.
Fly high, Mint.
Yeah, I think next episode is pretty good, so...
Um...
For people who thought that there were...
or had complaints about the first episode, like...
some things...
I think we improved upon it in the second episode.
So...
Yeah...
Cinderathalos, thank you!
Um...
Ume Haino, thank you again!
Spank, thank you!
Uh...
Kamendachi, thank you!
Seymour, thank you!
Kevarn, thank you!
Rico, thank you!
Um...
Korin, thank you!
Savictiv... Savicticus, thank you!
Um...
Mintyfreshkyle, thank you!
Israfel, thank you!
Kinkykidubber, thank you!
Um...
Never realized it was that expensive.
Because, like, at least four of my friends have pilot licenses for their Crop Duster.
That's crazy!
Everyone had to spend so much!
I'm surprised people had complaints about the first episode.
There were...
I say complaints, but it was really, like, constructive criticism.
You know?
And we asked for it.
We said, like, please, please give us constructive criticism since we've never done a podcast before.
And so we are looking to improve as much as we can, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Will there be another Patreon video?
Yes, there will be!
Yup, yup.
Which actually is almost the same length as...
As the podcast!
Oh my gosh, what was that gif?
We ended up talking so much in the Patreon video too, so...
Yeah...
Um...
What was it?
Oh!
We brought up the spy animals.
It's more fresh on my mind because we recorded it just a couple days ago, so...
Um...
Thank you, Cadaver, thank you!
Corrin, thank you!
DuckDuck, thank you!
Kamendachi, thank you!
This is your captain speaking.
If you want this plane to land, someone has to beat me in a children's card game!
That's what they should do.
You know how, like, when sometimes they can't land because they're waiting for, like, their spot to, uh...
To, um...
In line to, like, be able to use the runway?
They should just have it so that, um...
They should just, like...
Invite the passengers to, um...
Play games.
Come on, captain.
That's what I would do.
I would be that...
Oh my gosh, you know how there's, like, cool moms?
I'm the cool captain.
I let you...
I let you, um...
Land with your...
With your tray table down.
I...
You know, you don't have to stow those belongings.
Don't worry about it.
I'm... I'm so cool.
Coolest captain ever.
I'm not like other captains.
I'm the cool captain.
Uh...
Thank you!
Flight sim is extremely accurate with the controls.
From what I remember.
If you make it so, it can be pretty intense.
Cool!
I'm excited.
Thank you!
Wait.
Oh, I read all these.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh, I just realized.
Um...
Thank you!
If they can shoot lasers into your eyes, they can make lasers shoot out of your eyes.
Oh, can't they make...
Yeah, can't they make lasers shoot out of our eyes?
So true.
Captain Welfare, thank you!
Mr. Fowl, thank you!
Sideways, thank you!
Nicole, thank you!
Corrin, thank you!
Um...
J Ikeda?
J L Keda?
Is it... I think it's an I.
Thank you!
Uh...
Rabbit, thank you!
JB Hut, thank you!
Corrin, thank you!
Derpy's Derp, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Rungby Rabbit, thank you!
Thank you for the stream.
It was a lot of fun seeing you enjoy your childhood game again.
Thank you so much!
Thanks for the stream.
Very nostalgic seeing this game again.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys.
Appreciate it so much.
Um...
Inane, thank you!
Rico, thank you!
Pinkerton, thank you!
Pokidona, thank you!
Hypothetical lunch money.
I usually skip lunch.
But dinner funds are where I draw the line.
Maybe.
Sometimes.
That's okay.
I get it.
Oh wait, where did I leave off on?
Oh, here we go.
Ria, thank you!
I don't have any money, but you can have the rest of this moon pie I'm eating.
Why did you send that card?
Misfits, thank you!
This game is a few years older than me.
But it's really timeless.
Even if the hardest difficulties are so brutal.
Thank you for the fun, Mint.
I'm glad.
I'm glad that, uh...
Yeah, it really is timeless though.
It's so true.
Manthy Rose, thank you!
Such a joy to see you live.
I've started singing Snake Eater during my vocal practices because of you.
Oh my gosh.
You probably sound like...
You're probably insane levels then.
If that's your practice song.
Mia, thank you!
Pirate606, thank you!
I think you need a little bit more O's in your name.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you!
I was...
Oh, I never played Zumbini's in my childhood.
But I was so obsessed with Gizmos and Gadgets.
I never played that either.
I didn't play so many kids games, I think.
I did do a lot of Neopets though.
It was amazing watching you get so excited to revisiting this.
Yeah, I haven't played it since I was a kid.
So...
It was awesome.
Mr. Fel, thank you!
Yulian, thank you!
TV Dinner Tray, thank you!
Looking forward to Podcast Monday.
Fly Highman, thank you so much!
David Titanium!
Pepe, thank you!
Virlet, thank you!
Nexidava, thank you!
Adonimous, thank you!
Airborne Ninja, thank you!
I got a scholarship from my local experimental aviation association to get my...
Wait.
Experimental Aviation Association!
Aviation Association!
That sounds so awesome.
To get my license.
Might be something to look into.
It would be cheaper and easier for you to get the sport pilot license, which is mainly for ultralight planes or paragliders.
Okay, I'm actually going to look into that.
That sounds so awesome.
That are all the donations!
Thank you guys!
Thank you for sticking to the very end.
You didn't have to.
But I appreciate it so much.
I hope you all have a wonderful rest of your day.
Or your night.
Or your morning.
Whatever.
I guess day would be appropriate there.
But I'm gonna go to the store and see if that cake that I want is there.
See you guys on Tuesday!
Tuesday!
Riko, thank you!
Thank you!
Most of the cost of a pilot's license is renting a plane for $150 to $250 per hour for the FAA mandated 40 hours of flight time.
Plus however much extra time is needed to pass the check ride.
If you already have access to a plane, the cost goes way down.
I'm gonna talk to my old boss and see if he would actually be willing to...
to teach...
Not teach me, but like...
Maybe I can shadow him and see what goes into flying a plane.
I'm gonna see.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna become...
I'm gonna become a pilot VTuber.
You wanna borrow my plane?
Is it okay?
Can I borrow your plane?
The webinars guy?
Thank you!
Rodrigo, thank you!
I was sick and missed the stream.
Feel better!
Feel better, feel better.
Alright.
Bye bye!
Have a nice trip!
My old boss and young lady!
Bye bye!
See you!
Oh, you can still hear me!
I forgot!
I forgot.
It's so loud!
I'm so sorry!
Oh, I forgot that I still had the mic on me.
Say
Otsu Minto!
I just said, itterashai!
Otsu...
Minto!